Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Hello,
Dr.
so high,
tap it and pull this sucker from your
face.
There you go.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Thanks for doing this.
Appreciate it.
Thank you for having me.
Uh,
I've watched a bunch of your videos,
have listened to a bunch of your talks,
read a bunch of your work.
Very interesting person.
And this is a good time for a person
like you.
Things seem to be kind of scrambled a
little bit.
Yeah.
A little topsy turvy out there these
days.
A little bit crazy.
So you're a sex neuroscientist,
is that an accurate description?
I'm a former
academic sex researcher,
uh,
my Phd's in sexual neuroscience research
and now I work as a science journalist
and a columnist.
And why former
because the climate and academia has
changed so much,
like you mentioned how things are topsy
turvy,
but that's pretty much how you can
describe academia nowadays.
Even in the hard sciences.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's getting a little weird.
What do you attribute it to?
I think it's a combination of things.
I think it's a particular ideologies
coming in and taking over,
but they've been there for awhile,
but I think it's at that they've reached
the mainstream.
I see it as political correctness
running a mock and I see it as
legitimate researchers not being able to
speak out because they've got enough on
their plate with their research,
their teaching.
They've got their students,
you know,
they're super busy and then on top of it
they don't want to deal with the mobbing
that will inevitably happen if they do
speak out.
So things are kind of in favor right now
of the craziness.
But it's fascinating though as an
outsider to watch the craziness.
I bet.
I mean I'm glad I don't have to be in
school right now and deal with it,
but to watch it from the outside,
it's just so interesting.
Interesting.
In what way though?
Well,
because it's almost like there's a sort
of a delusional aspect to it,
like a,
a,
an agreed upon delusional aspect.
It's like,
like the gender one in particular,
that gender is very strange right now.
Like,
um,
there's a,
there's first of all the Lbgtq.
I a what else?
Et cetera.
Is there,
and they're adding more to it.
They keep adding more yet to be more
inclusive.
Okay.
Jamie,
something going on.
Focus is fucked up.
Oh,
what's going on?
I got it.
All right.
I thought maybe we were down again.
Um,
yeah,
it just.
But gender in particular.
One of the things I said about one of
the more bizarre things about today's
political climate is that people
selectively agree with science.
It's like when it comes to client
climate change,
like everybody is like pro science,
like science all the way.
Look at the studies.
Even when they don't even understand the
studies.
Like there's a famous and you know,
I get in trouble when you bring up
Tucker Carlson because people go,
oh,
you're a target Carlson fan.
I'm
just as a human being,
I'm not going to make.
He made some very good points with Bill
Nye.
He had bill Nye on.
They were talking about science and he
said,
okay,
if human beings are responsible for
climate change,
what percentage?
What are the numbers like?
Bill Nye really isn't a scientist.
He's a science.
You know?
What would your personality,
those immediate personality,
he's a guy who's a,
you know,
he's a promoter of science,
but not really necessarily scientist,
so he's.
He doesn't,
he doesn't have long term study and
research to climate change.
He's just sort of on there in a slightly
arrogant way saying things that I agree
with.
What I agree with is that human beings
are responsible,
at least in part with climate change.
This is what all the research points to,
but when Tucker Carlson was pressing him
on it,
he really didn't have any answers for
it,
so it's one of those things where like
people on the left will blindly support
science in one way.
Is that you or me?
Dang it.
If it's me,
I'm going to be very upset with myself.
I don't think it's me,
but then when it comes to gender,
you watch his show.
He's got this wacky show on Netflix
where they're.
They're singing songs about gender can
be fluid and gender could be.
This is more than two.
Yeah.
There's more than two genders,
which he didn't use to say.
If you go back to one of his old.
I did see that there was another episode
where they clearly say that gender is
binary.
Yeah.
This was like way back before all this
nuttiness staff,
so it's influencing people who are in
the people are deciding instead of
supporting science and supporting the
research on actual human beings as a
biological organism.
Instead we're going with this bizarre
politically correct climate which
inclines people to this weird delusional
thinking and as an outsider,
that's what's interesting to me to watch
all this scrambling,
look at this weirdness.
You know,
it's hypocritical.
It definitely is.
And it's interesting to see.
I mean say the March for Science,
I attended that not this past year but
the year before.
So people are there.
They're super excited about science,
pro science.
I think science is great.
All this money should go into science
and you ask them,
okay,
so you're.
So you're down for climate change being
real,
but what about science?
Now by the left and I asked so many
people this while I was there because I
was reporting on it for playboy.com
and it's amazing.
People get very uncomfortable.
They don't want to.
They don't want to say anything about I
would consider myself to be a liberal,
but definitely liberals don't want to
think about themselves being science
deniers and when you look at how people
talk about gender now and biological sex
differences in the brain,
even biology more generally,
people get very defensive.
They get angry almost,
and if they find it threatening for some
reason,
which I don't understand,
and that's a big part of my work is to
say,
I think we can acknowledge that these
facts exist and that biological sciences
legitimate.
That doesn't mean that sexism is okay.
We're not saying that women are inferior
or anything like that.
Exactly.
That's the big point about all this,
right,
is that we're not saying that anyone's
inferior,
but we're just not the same thing.
This is what the big problem is to try
to say,
uh,
I mean,
I,
I certainly think we should all have
equal rights,
but we're not equal in terms of what we
are.
We're a different we're.
And it's not that we're not equal,
like one's better.
It's just like saying a wolf is not
equal to achieve their fucking different
things and males and females are
different things and this is,
this is clear when you study us as an
organism,
you know,
I had a really bizarre conversation once
with a guy who's a professor or a former
professor and he was trying to deny that
there there's a difference between men
and women and one of the things I said,
I said,
okay,
you get a dog.
Do you ask,
is this a boy dog or a girl dog?
And then he got real weird,
but this is really no answer to that.
Like it's a fucking boy dog.
You want a boy dog,
right?
Is it a nonbinary dog?
Like what is your dog?
It might change.
It's fine to Milo your dog gender fluid.
Like what is gender fluid?
Well,
it's this idea that you can be one
gender one day and another gentleman the
other day or it might cycle through the
day or doesn't your mix of both.
That seems like if it was anything else,
you would have to be fucking crazy.
Right?
It was.
Anything else you feel like if you
decided,
well today I'm African,
tomorrow I'm Chinese,
you know,
oh,
today I'm tall tomorrow.
I'm short today.
I'm a Pixie tomorrow,
but what else like that?
I think everybody is.
We don't have to call it something like
gender fluid.
Everyone is a mix of male and female.
Have people that are maybe more
typically masculine and feminine,
but even still there,
I don't think there are many people that
are 100 percent one way or the other
not.
Well,
what does that even mean?
I mean,
people are clearly more masculine than
other people,
but does that mean that the people like,
you know,
let's pick a person,
Bill Nye.
Does that mean he's not a man?
He's clearly a man.
He's not a Lebron James,
but he's a man.
You know,
there's,
there's obviously a spectrum,
but I almost feel like that way of
thinking is more old fashioned because
this is all about being progressive and
open minded,
but I think if someone is a man,
but it's maybe more female typical to
say that this person has a different
category of gender or that they're not
mail,
to me that's more stereotypical.
You know what I mean?
I think it's not progressive to say if
you're a mix of both,
you must be something different.
Well,
you're not necessarily a mix of both,
right?
You just have a different hormonal
profile are different.
It's a different body types.
Different.
I mean people vary so much that.
I mean I think having some sort of
categories to say,
oh,
this is a male and this is a female.
It seems like pretty beneficial.
I mean although we vary so widely inside
those categories to pretend that those
categories don't exist just seems so
weird.
We would never do that with any other
organism and it's a lot work to.
You see
these companies going in,
they're trying to be more and with the
times I guess are there.
Everything is gender neutral now and I'm
thinking all of that money and time is
being wasted when I don't think that
does anything for,
for women or sexism.
If you changed instead of addressing
someone by ladies and gentlemen,
you say people.
Is that really gonna stop sexism.
It just makes people mad because then
they have to change the way they talk.
I put a story on twitter the other day
about people that are raising their kids
with them.
I saw that.
Yeah,
calling them babies instead of babies.
Oftentimes.
What the fuck is that like her?
Just.
I think it's coming from.
For some parents that's coming from a
good place,
like they obviously want the best for
their kids and they don't want to limit
the kid in terms of what they might be
interested and I think because the media
is telling them if you let girls play
with dolls,
that's terrible and they're going to end
up,
you know,
not having any sort of prospects when
they grow up in terms of their jobs or I
don't know,
it's such a terrible thing to be female.
Typical nowadays,
but I mean like you mentioned is
biology.
That's going to dictate what your kids
play with.
And then in other cases I think it's
parents that want to be special.
Well,
it's also weird because if your son is
trans,
it's totally fine for him to be female.
Typical like it's celebrated.
Like if you have a trans son and he
likes wearing lipstick and short skirts
and prints and around then he's
fabulous.
Like there was a boy in New York and
there was this whole thing about he's
the youngest ever drag queen and and
everybody's going crazy and people were
angry about it,
you know?
Yeah.
Some people were angry and saying he was
being exploited by his parents and some
people thought it was wonderful that
this kid was so expressive when he's so
young,
and then other people say,
I had a good point.
They said,
well,
it's very sexualized.
Like how is this any different than
someone who's in a beauty pageant like
Jon Benet Ramsey type situation when
were really young.
If it was a little girl,
people would be up in arms sexist and
that it's the patriarchy,
but that little boy,
so I don't know that he's trans.
I believe that he just likes to like,
like a man who's a drag queen is just a
man.
It's usually gay men who likes to,
you know,
like an extreme form of femininity.
I love drag Queens,
but I think that little boy is likely
going to grow up to be a gay boy.
If you have a little boy who says he's a
girl and you see a lot of these trans
girls,
if they were left alone and they didn't
transition,
they would likely research shows they
would grow up to be gay men is.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm 100 percent for freedom,
right,
so I'm 100 percent for you being able to
do whatever you want to do.
The real question becomes when people
are Trans and young,
it's a how much,
how much of this is going to pass and
how much of this are you going to stop
from ever passing because you're going
to inject your body filled with
hormones,
like are you giving yourself the
opportunity just to decide to become a
gay man versus become a woman?
Would you be happier either or.
It's very,
very tricky,
but you can't even have that
conversation because that's considered
transphobic.
What it is is homophobic though that you
can consider that some of these kids
just might be gay children.
Yeah,
but then the.
The gender fluid one.
I was reading this article about this
guy who varies by the day and like in
the day like he'll have periods of
stress will switch over to a woman.
There was actually a radiolab podcast
where they interviewed a person that has
the same issue and the person was
clearly abnormal in the way they
communicated and the way they thought.
It wasn't like you were dealing with
some guy that you would trust with your
taxes.
You know what I mean?
It was like the dude was wacky and then
now he's a check and now he's back to
being a guy and so he actually
transitioned in mid conversation,
like physically I didn't see it because
it's just listening.
Okay,
okay.
But he's like,
well,
now I'm Peter again.
Oh,
I see what you mean.
Not Wendy.
Hi Wendy.
Well,
it's.
I don't know how much of that is
indulgent.
I mean,
I don't want.
I don't want to say I know how you feel,
but I do want to say,
hey,
are you fucking crazy?
Is this,
are we just.
Are we just indulging crazy people and
how to be.
I do believe there are people that are
trans.
I absolutely believe that there are
women that really are wired the wrong
way and they should be men and there's
men that are wired the wrong.
It only makes sense.
Yeah,
but I do also think there's people that
are crazy.
There's people that have legit mental
illness,
they're delusional and they're also very
susceptible to influence and very
susceptible to,
you know,
someone persuading them that they are
one thing or another thing.
Look,
it's those like heaven's gate cult
people who cut their balls off and wore
the Nike's and decided to kill
themselves when the comment was near
number that yeah,
that's not normal.
It's not normal for someone to be able
to talk to you any cutting your balls
off or putting on the purple sneakers or
killing yourself when the comments close
because there's a spaceship waiting.
It's going to take you to Xenu or
wherever the fuck you going.
Right.
That's not normal either.
So we know that people are subject to
very irrational behavior under the
influence of other people's suggestions
or other people's,
you know,
persuasion.
Yeah,
definitely.
And this is a thing today where you have
to wonder like how many of these people
are legitimately trans,
how many of these people are
legitimately dealing with like a real
mental issue that's causing them to
shift from male to female and back
again?
And why is it that we can't ask these
questions because why is it that even
this question right now,
I could be accused of being transphobic
for asking how many of these people are
ill?
Yeah.
Well both of us were going to be accused
of transphobia after this.
Yeah,
I mean,
I would agree with that.
I do think that gender dysphoria is a
phenomenon and I do have a lot of
empathy for people who are suffering.
And I think for adults,
they should be allowed to transition if
that's what they decide to do,
if that's something that will help them
feel better.
My issues with the kids,
uh,
it's,
I don't think it's appropriate for
children to be transitioning.
And I can talk a bit more about why,
but I think in terms of the pathology
aspect,
I think for,
because gender is so trendy right now,
and in the past you might have seen this
kind of pathology manifests in a
different way,
but now because everyone is saying is
the way to express,
you know,
I think people also see a fever problem
in your life.
They think it's gender related,
so say with some of the personality
disorder and people like a lot of
attention,
they like to,
um,
it's always about them and their
identity and their identity shifts a
lot.
So this could very well be what it is
and now they're being basically rewarded
for that.
Yeah,
that's the issue,
right?
That you're dealing with incredibly
indulgent people which do exist and they
then they find this pathway to massive
amounts of attention.
You know what I mean?
This is,
I,
I had to construct a bit to mock Caitlyn
Jenner,
but it was a very complicated bit like I
had to figure out how to do this.
I was like,
obviously this is nonsense and foolish,
but I don't want to appear cruel,
so what is the way to do this?
So my way was to mock myself mercilessly
and which is kind of true.
Like I really do have three daughters
and I really do get brutalized in my
house.
Like I really do think they chip away at
my note.
It's kind of a joke,
but I mean it really is.
It's all girly in my house.
My fucking house is so girly.
Everyone's girly.
They're always talking about girly shit.
It's kind of hilarious.
But the joke was that if my manhood was
a mountain of marbles,
every day they take two marbles,
they just take one like you don't even
need these,
these,
what do you care?
God.
And then that I'm not going to go out
like Bruce Jenner,
that one the one day that they.
So I had to concoct this whole thing
that they were demons,
which is how they conjured up all that
money.
Like how else would they have hundreds
of millions of dollars through no
discernible reason.
There's no,
there's no way you could like explain to
someone how they made so much money if
they didn't understand our culture.
It's totally irrational.
Right?
So the idea was that that they did this,
but why did it was I wanted to sort of
mock this thing that was happening where
you've got a male Kardashians.
That's what he does.
And who doesn't believe in gay marriage?
Who decides he's a woman,
which I firmly believe he's trans.
I'm not denying that at all,
but our obsession with it and rewarding
him with ungodly amounts of attention.
This motherfucker won the gold medal in
the decathlon.
Was it?
The calphalon was right?
Yeah.
I mean he was on the cover wheaties.
I mean he was a fucking us superstar
athlete and then no attention after
that,
he was the whipping boy of the
Kardashians on their TV show.
They mocked him.
It was like,
here's this one with fucking talent.
Your don't.
They mock rob a bit fat,
but then they go right to that.
He becomes a woman and now he is the
toast of the town.
He wins woman of the fucking year.
He's a woman for six months and he wins
woman of the year.
He Wins Espn athlete of the year.
He has been an athlete in fucking
decades since Nixon was president,
right?
Or Carter,
who was it?
Either way,
this is madness.
This is where we're not treating this in
a balanced way where we are rewarding
people that instead of like,
because people are so,
they're,
they're so ready to proclaim the
progressiveness and so excited about it
that they instead of like,
instead of treating them as an equal,
they go completely the other way.
So there are definitely not prejudice.
They're definitely not discriminating
against them,
but they're absolutely inflating what
this person is and,
and they're making it a big giant deal
that they're trans.
Like it's great to support people.
I would like to live in a world where
there's no racism at all,
so you could mock everyone equally.
Like,
this is my big problem with real racism.
There's a lot of dummies in every race,
but you gotta be real careful picking on
some dummies,
like specially if you're a white male,
straight,
white male oppressor.
You guys are the devil nowadays,
especially if you look like me.
I mean I looked like the devil,
so this is a.
This is a real problem with like looking
at things in a balanced perspective
because you're not allowed to not
allowed.
Like even what you said earlier,
you said gender dysphoria,
you know,
that's considered transphobic.
Yeah.
You can't even say that anymore even
though that is a legitimate medical
condition because some people see it as
you pathologizing being the way someone
feels,
I guess,
but in my mind I don't think the issue
is pathology.
The pathology,
I think it's fine to acknowledge there
are certain things like any,
any medical condition that causes you
distress and impairment.
That's the definition of a psychiatric
diagnosis,
so you should be able to recognize that
it's not a bad thing.
I think the bad thing is the stigma that
comes along with having a mental
disorder,
so that's what should be fought.
It's the stigma aspect,
not calling something a mental disorder.
If someone's.
If someone's really suffering,
that's not a good thing.
No,
no.
It's not a good thing.
And also the denial of these conditions
and the denial of the science behind
these conditions.
This is the issue with progressive
people today is that there's certain
things where they embrace science and
certain things where they deny it and in
gender,
gender in particular seems to be so
hotly contested and I don't know when
this happened,
it seems to have happened right in front
of our face.
Like it,
it just came out of the ground,
like a plant that was growing in the
crack
now to let try to stomp it out and it
won't go away.
I'm wondering,
I'm wondering where the shit.
Like I didn't see this coming and it's,
it's fascinating to see.
I think feminism is part of it.
The mainstream aspect of this really far
left feminism.
I used to call myself a feminist.
I don't anymore just because the things
that people used to say feminism stood
for like hating men being a.
I don't know,
just don't say that.
Well,
some of them do.
They say they hate men.
Oh yeah.
I have friends who say my male friends
who say to me,
you know,
my female friends said the men are
trash.
Is that normal?
Well,
there's a woman that I know that's a
feminist that has on her,
uh,
her twitter account.
It says,
trust.
No Man,
like just openly proclaiming that if
you're straight,
good luck.
Good luck with your life.
You're saying trust.
No Man.
But imagine if you said about women,
you know,
terrible thing.
Yeah,
that would be,
that'd be awful as well.
But it's acceptable to hate on men now.
Well,
nobody criticizes misandry,
you know,
it's just,
it's not something that is,
that gets brought up.
I don't even,
I've never even said that worked before.
I've only written it and set it or
written it and heard it.
I mean,
I get it.
I do.
I think feminism at the core had some
good aspects in the beginning,
but it's just gone off the rails more
recently.
Equality has great aspects,
but I think the problem with any like
white power is obviously awful.
You say white power.
Well you're,
you're.
What you mean is your racist against
other races.
You're into white people,
but brown powers.
Okay.
Brown prides.
Right.
Nowadays they see it that way.
Yeah.
Male pride is not okay.
Not Okay,
but girl pride is fine.
Girl power is okay.
Yeah.
It's fucking weird because you're.
You're,
you're generalizing.
You're lumping yourself into a group of
people just because you all have vaginas
and we don't all think the same,
but the minute you as a woman say
something that goes against girl power,
they will descend on you.
Yes.
I've seen that too.
Well,
it's like you're threatening the
collective agreed upon narrative and you
are.
It's like you like the way girls treat
sluts.
Girls get very mad if a girl just
decides to have sex as many people as
she wants because then you're fucking up
this whole economy of controlling the
narrative of when women decide to or
not.
Sex goes down that way too.
Which is why prostitution's illegal.
I see both sides.
I see some women,
which I.
which I find interesting because I think
it's confusing for young women now who
are starting to date and they think I
don't really want to have casual sex,
but I'm being told that's what I should
do.
Is that what they're being told?
I think so.
I think by whom?
By the media more like it's empowering
to go out and sleep with as many people
as you want and to be like a man,
like if you look at college campuses and
how there's quite a bit of casual sex
going on and I don't think that's
for everyone.
I think from an evolutionary perspective
to women don't like that as much.
I was talking to a friend of mine today
about this,
uh,
who's in the military and he was saying
what's crazy about certain branches of
the military is you have like 100 men to
one women to one woman and one woman,
especially if they're deployed and this,
they have the pick of the litter and
they'll just fuck her gang of dudes.
Same time I would never talked about.
I've never thought about it that way
before,
but he was like,
you know,
well everybody just sort of agrees that
nobody has this one girl that nobody is
going to own her and that she can have
sex with as many guys as she wants to.
Like the,
what he was saying is like,
at least in his experience that the
whole dynamic of male female
relationships shift and these girls can
basically date as many of these guys
that she wants.
It was kind of interesting and they
don't shame her for that.
Well,
they can't because there's only one.
It's like they don't want her to get
angry at them too.
It's like I didn't talk to them about it
a lot.
We always spoke about it for like 10
minutes,
but it was like this.
That's kind of crazy.
I never even thought about that dynamic
like that.
That sort of a scenario where there's
100 men in one chick.
That's a lot of men.
Good luck with all that.
You can get sore and you'd be like
annoyed,
like really cute.
Let me alone and you're going to sleep.
How much time does she have?
You know?
Yeah,
especially if you're in the military,
you've got tasks,
things you need to do.
Yeah,
but it's the dynamics shift according to
like what is available and who's there
and what kind of a culture you live in.
People adapt are very malleable to
different climates and different
cultures and the way people treat sex
and don't treat sex and this is when I
think what happens is people tend to
react very aggressively or very strongly
when someone is doing something that is
different than the way they're doing
things because this would possibly
indicate that there's another way or
maybe their was wrong or maybe it's
just.
And especially when it comes to sex,
people get very strange.
They do like when people find out that
people are in open relationships.
I have a good friend of mine who's in an
open relationship and it's so
fascinating to watch all the people.
You have guys fuck your girlfriend,
Bro.
And he asked to sort of discuss it and
the gas.
This is,
it's not comfortable for me.
I wish I enjoyed it.
I enjoy it.
So why do they have an open
relationship?
I don't know.
I mean they have to talk to them about
it.
I mean he's got bunch of different
answers.
I think the main answer is he wants to
fuck other people and she wants to fuck
other people and so they just decided to
do it that way and they were together in
a monogamous relationship for for
awhile,
but I think I am correct.
I think they've been in an open
relationship longer than they were in a
monogamous relationship with a for.
I would have to ask him I think
more than a year,
maybe two years or something like that.
And then it's been like four years of
open.
Open relationships are actually pretty
common.
Consensual nonmonogamous.
There's one study that showed one in
five Americans have actually tried it,
so it's pretty common.
Me Personally,
I'm monogamous,
but I think people should do what they
want to do.
If it's consensual.
I think obviously having been a sex
researcher and now someone who writes
about sex research for a living,
I'm very sex positive and I think a lot
of the problems that we see in a lot of
the suffering and distress and issues
that people have in their lives could be
solved.
If our world was more sex positive,
we could just talk about sex like
anything else,
right?
The shame of it is the real problem and
this is what I'm saying with that people
when you're living a life that's
different than the way they're living
their life,
they.
People get very aggressive about it.
Same Way.
I mean sober.
People tend to get aggressive about
people enjoy drinking or people enjoy
smoking pot or taking mushrooms or
something.
They get very shitty about it sometimes
and it's because it's very polar,
very,
very opposite of the way they're living
their life and they don't want to see
anybody living their life in a very
different way,
but also being happy.
They think,
well,
this is not how I do it and this is
contrary to my values,
so you must be doing something wrong or
you need alcohol to get by.
Is that what you need?
You need to like,
oh,
you don't need that drink.
I don't want it.
I just have it.
If I have a glass of wine,
I get happy.
Who's getting hurt here and what?
You're going to start doing heroin.
Then you're going to wind up in the
gutter.
I've never have never been on heroin,
never been in the gutter,
been alive for a while.
Nothing's happened.
Can be a bit of projection too.
For sure.
Someone who's dealt with substance
issues that the fear that you know,
it's very easy for someone else to fall
down the same hole.
Right,
but it's this thing that people living a
different way is somehow or another
threatening,
unacceptable and threatening to their
perceptions of what,
what you should be doing with your life.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and I think,
I mean this is very unrelated to the
hole,
but it's not.
It's what,
when it comes to gender,
I think there's just this thing that
people,
people want things to be more easily
explained than they are.
That's true.
I could see that because it takes a lot
of work to actually go.
So people who say that gender is a
social construct,
that's a good one.
Sounds very nice.
I love saying that.
It's not saying that,
but it's infuriating because it's
everywhere now.
Like this is what children are being
taught in school up in Canada.
That's what they're being taught in
their curriculum.
And there's absolutely no truth to it at
all.
But I mean if you read the scientific
studies,
you cannot come away from them saying
gender's a social construct.
There's the argument for it if you were
arguing for it that uh,
I guess the,
the idea is that women should be equal.
And obviously as a woman,
I believe that.
And so
any sort of subjugation of women must
somehow be imposed by society because if
we acknowledged that women are different
biologically in any way that's going to
be used as justification why they don't
deserve to be treated the same as men or
they're not as capable as men,
but yes,
different subjugation and why is
different incapable?
Why is different
in fairness?
Because there has been a history of
there being sexism and say.
So with the whole Google memo thing and
this idea that women are biologically,
we are different.
Not to say we're not as capable,
but if there are any sort of biological
correlates to what women find
interesting,
could that be extrapolated to capability
extrapolated to women should go back to
the kitchen.
The women aren't good at math,
things like that.
I mean I get why people don't like
biological explanations for things I
didn't.
Like you said,
I think it's just a lot easier and it's
a lazy way to just dismiss the whole
thing and say,
you know,
we don't need to think about it.
Nothing to see here.
Yeah.
But it just,
it's clearly not true in terms of the
scientific research,
so there has to be some cognitive
dissonance in order to accept that and
to preach it and to say it and everybody
has to agree upon it,
which is one of the reasons why I think
any,
any statements contrary to that get
aggressively attack.
And this is part of the reason why these
ideas are so supercharged.
It's that there's,
there's a,
there's an understanding that it's
horseshit.
And so when someone challenges it and
says it's Horseshit,
you've been living your whole life with
this horseshit.
It's almost like a religious thing.
Yeah.
Well,
okay.
I think some people know what the truth
is and they actively lie because they
think they're doing something good for
women.
So they'll say gender is a social
construct even though they know it's
biological.
And I think people who are younger may
be going through school.
Now we're being taught there's actually
don't know the difference and actually
believe it,
but why would they aggressively attack
the scientific research that's contrary
to that claim?
Then?
You mean the people who don't know any
better?
They actually believe that gender is a
social construct and these scientists
are just sexist and misogynistic.
Want to keep women down,
but I.
I can get that if you didn't research
it,
if you didn't look into it,
but once you start looking into it,
you go,
oh,
well this is weird,
but there's clearly.
Do you think people actually look into
it though?
I don't think they do.
The sense I get is they.
They find someone or some journalists
who has had some sort of decent sounding
criticism of the literature and they
just pair it that I don't think they
actually go and look at the studies.
Well,
I think there's part of.
There's definitely something to that and
I think there's something to this
problem that human beings have where
they.
They have an idea and that idea becomes
a part of their identity and then they
start arguing for that idea and any
argument against that idea is an
argument against them as a person
because they're trying to win.
They're not necessarily looking at
things in an objective way where they're
detached
from the idea and studying it as a
thing.
Instead they're arguing to try to win.
I think that is a giant problem with
ideas and in yes,
and it becomes even more of a problem
when it gets tribal.
When these ideas are attached,
like climate change,
clearly attached in denial to the right
in support to the left.
It's this very strange tribal thing and
that also happens with gender and it
also like if you are in support of of
women's rights and you are in support of
trans rights and Lbgtq and all that
jazz,
you're almost 100 percent going to be on
the left.
It's just one of those tribal things.
If you're pro choice,
you're almost always going to be on the
left.
If you're not,
you find yourself in that.
Which one was.
It was a Tammy Lauren.
I get her confused with that.
Lauren southern girls.
Those girls are interchangeable in some
strange way.
Those the,
the hot Republicans and Tomi Lahren,
Tomi Lahren,
she's pro choice.
She got attacked.
Can Be can be.
You want to be on this team,
you want to be on the main white girl
team.
You can't be project you gotTa,
you gotta be prolife.
What about life?
What about the baby's support debate?
We,
you know what I'm saying was like some
ideas get locked into ideologies.
They get locked into these tribal
ideologies and gender is most certainly
one of those because people don't want
to be without a political home.
Right?
That's a very good way of putting it
because if you do say,
say someone like Tommy Tommy who is,
why do I call it Tammy?
Because I'm an asshole.
She in trouble.
Tomi Lahren will star in pro life film
after the break.
The blaze fired her for being pro
choice.
What if you're a pro choice conservative
or if you're a pro biology liberal,
you know,
you kind of find yourself in a weird.
In between.
So she's just fucking going the other
way.
She's going the other way.
She's gonna start a film.
What's a pro life film?
So ABC after school special.
Don't have an abortion.
Have your baby.
Yeah,
it's weird.
Well,
she's got to get our ground back to
kicked off the team a little bit.
It's a bio pic on the Roe vs Wade case
starting Stacey Dash.
Oh,
so,
so maybe she's playing a bad person in
that movie.
Made it even more interesting.
Strange.
I wonder how many of those things are
just distractions.
You know,
it's so weird.
People are so weird with their,
their,
their tribal identities.
You know,
I,
I just,
and I love when they go back and forth
and shift from one side or the other.
I'd love it when like,
wow,
I'm a former conservative scene.
The light or you know,
I used to be a liberal to the party.
Lost me.
I love that.
And then they go hardcore on the other
side is weird because it's ever.
Then everything is not just a couple of
views.
It's everything in alignment with the
other side to join a church.
Stopped doing drugs.
Yeah,
it's fascinating.
It's fascinating.
Um,
as a neuroscientist when something like
the Google memo comes out,
you are also a woman and you are also a
woman who lost a person of color,
sort of.
Are you as I work,
you're lighter than me?
Well,
you're a different color.
Am My a person of color telling then I
have the bolt.
You can be an honorary person of color,
I'll give you that bad.
But I'm Sicilian so there's somebody.
My background got fucked by somebody who
was darker for sure,
but I don't know how that works because
if I was Cuban I would look exactly the
same and I definitely could be a person
of color I think is ridiculous.
I can't stand that term for the record
person of color because those of us who
are not white,
we don't all think the same,
but we all get lumped in as having some
sort of a wider conversation with a
friend of mine about that who was
Mexican and he was talking about Latinos
and I go,
well you do know that Italian was one of
the original Latin languages,
like I am Latino.
If you look at it that way,
like what is Latino?
Like you just thinking it was only
Spanish.
That's not really the technical
definition of it isn't Latinos?
I mean am I correct about that?
I mean,
it doesn't emanate from a Latin language
think so I think so too,
but it's just like Italians had been so
ingrained in our culture.
They came over so long ago that like,
you know,
my grandparents came here in the
twenties so that that's a hundred years
ago almost,
so it doesn't count.
It doesn't count anymore.
You're not really discriminated against
anymore.
It's like Jews used to be.
It's what's interesting is if you follow
boxing history,
and I know you're a martial artist,
you follow boxing history,
the oppressed early immigrants are
almost always the best boxers at the
time and for awhile it was a lot of
Jewish boxers,
a lot of Italian boxers.
Of course,
you know,
rocky Graziano and rocky Marciano and
all these towns,
and then it became a Cubans and Puerto
Ricans and then it became,
well there was always blacks as well,
but this like immigrants in particular,
Irish,
a lot of Irish immigrants that early on
they were thought of as being some of
the lowliest of the low and now Irish
people are 100 percent white,
like no one even thinks about it.
Of course they're white,
but I mean they're,
they're just American Asian.
Soon we're going to be a hundred percent
white basically.
Well,
not of Harvard has anything to do with.
They're trying to kick you guys out.
What is it about not trying to kick you
guys out,
but that is one of the weirder
discriminations that is somehow or
another slipped under the radar that
they're making it more difficult for
Asians to get into Ivy League
universities because you guys do so
well.
I mean,
it,
it's racism,
racism,
and I think some of these people who are
getting pats on the back for being
progressive about being diverse,
I think they just don't
like us and now they have a politically
acceptable way to do it.
But why is that?
Why would they not like Asians?
Know some people just don't.
Some people are racist,
but is it that or is it that you guys do
too?
Well?
Well,
that's the thing.
I mean,
we throw that whole narrative into
question,
this idea that if you're not white,
you must,
uh,
you,
you can't be doing well in life.
You can't pull yourself up and get on
with things.
Yeah.
Well that was the argument against the
Charles Murray Book.
What was that book?
The bell curve?
Yes.
One of the problems with that book is
people were showing the differences in
ICU,
um,
by,
you know,
as it varies across different
geographical segments and across races
and if anything,
that book is really a testament to the
master race of Asians,
but for real,
right?
Like Asians,
we do okay.
But genetically like Asian people seem
to be superior when it comes to Iq
according to that book.
I think we just work really hard in our
culture.
Puts a lot of emphasis on education.
Did you read the talent code?
Really interesting book.
I'm finishing it up right now,
but one of the things about it is it's
sort of dismisses the idea of talent and
it shows.
It goes into depth about all the D,
not dismisses it,
but shows that it's not.
Some magic gift is bestowed upon people,
but what it is is it shows all the
pathways that lead to the skill
developments that we considered talent
and discipline and hard work in
particular discipline being a culturally
inforce thing,
which it is with many Asians.
I often talk about my friend junk sick
who when I was doing taekwondo,
he was on the US team while he was also
in his residency in medical school.
Sky was I fucking animal.
I'd,
I never met anybody in my life who
worked as hard as him.
He always looked exhausted.
This is face all the time.
I just was always tired,
but then would go to work like a fucking
savage was inbetween studying for his do
you know,
in the middle of a medical school and he
would put his backpack on,
filled with books and run the stairs at,
at the university.
He's fucking crazy,
but it's.
This is.
And I would,
I would talk to them about it,
you know,
because my parents were not like that
and his parents were like,
my parents were hippies and they were
like,
do whatever the fuck you want.
We don't care,
and his parents were like,
you must be a doctor,
and he was like telling me about the
kind of discipline that he grew up with
and that culturally enforced discipline
leads,
many,
many people to succeed.
Whereas,
you know,
the sort of latch key kids that I grew
up with,
there was no.
There was no culturally enforced
discipline.
You either developed it on your own,
you pursued something that you enjoyed
and figured out how to become discipline
or you just weren't you.
But this thing that's in Asian cultures
is what's propelling them forward.
If you subscribe to all the different
things that are being brought up in this
book,
the talent code and it makes sense.
It only makes sense.
I think it should be seen as a positive
thing that you know,
everyone is capable.
It's not just a particular race or a
particular group of people that can be
successful.
I mean,
my issue with the whole thing with the
Harvard law students that why are Asians
being punished for doing well,
essentially explained the lawsuit for
people that don't.
So it turns out that for decades now,
Harvard has been discriminating against
Asians and requiring them to have higher
sat scores than people of other ethnic
backgrounds in order to get the same
chance of admission.
And then more recently it's been shown
that,
okay,
so Asians do well with sat scores.
They do all the extra curricular
activities.
So the only way that admissions
committees can actually penalize them is
through writing their personality.
So seeing them as less likable,
things like that because they're
subjective and uh,
you know,
I find it amazing that very few liberal
outlets I've covered this.
Um,
the New York Times has been one,
but outside of that it's been very few
and it's really disappointing and no one
has.
I mean I wrote about this for the Globe
and Mail and I was amazed.
No one had heard about this story at
all.
Well,
not only that,
even when I was covering the New York
Times or burglar.
Okay.
Yeah.
Let's go on with our day dawn.
Like in and out.
Yeah.
Whereas if it was in about any other
subject or any other race or gender,
there's being discriminated against.
I mean if it was discrimination against
black people in the same systematic way
or systemic way,
it would be outrageous.
People go crazy.
Yeah,
and even more insane that you're doing
it to the most successful people.
The most successful in terms of
academics because that's the problem,
right?
The problem is helping society either.
I mean if if I were not Asian,
I would be saying the same thing.
I don't think it makes sense to take
people who are doing well and hold them
back.
If you,
if you want your society to do well,
I think the solution would be to help
people.
We're not doing as well.
Don't penalize the people who are doing
well.
Well,
I think there's a fear of Asians.
I'm not bullshitting and one of the.
I've been obsessed with this company
walway recently and what I got obsessed
with them for two reasons.
One,
because I read an article about the
superiority of the cell phones that
they're producing that are not being
accepted in America,
and so then I started doing.
I'm kind of a Dork when it comes to like
cell phones and technology.
I'm very fascinated by them,
so I read a lot of articles about walway
phones and they have these fucking
insane Leica cameras,
a 40 megapixel lenses,
three lenses on the front and 20 plus
Megapixel selfie cameras and like really
intense technology.
Much more,
much higher.
Like I think they have 500 gigabyte
storage capacity.
Four thousand milliamp batteries.
Like they're superior battery.
It's a superior phone and I'm looking
at.
I'm like,
wow,
this is kind of crazy.
And then it turns out you can't sell
them in the United States and the
federal government's blocked these
carriers from having them and they're
saying it's because the Chinese
government is involved in stealing
information and hacking and all this
different stuff.
I'm like,
okay,
all right.
Maybe but,
but,
but it's kind of fucking weird that you
can't figure out whether or not a phone
is being used to like,
how are these hackers,
how these super genius people who
program phones,
you can't look at one of those phones
and and figure out what it's doing
because he's doing some magic or,
or another.
It's stealing people's information and
there's no mechanism that you can
detect.
What do you think?
There's another reason why they are not
letting them know.
What I'm worried about is that they're
scared that these companies which are
fanatical,
maniacal in a aggressive pursuit of
dominance in the cell phone markets and
technology in general are going to take
over and they're going to squash all
these American companies.
And I was like,
how much.
I mean,
this is my own personal speculation,
but I'm looking at this.
I'm like,
how much?
How much legitimacy.
Isn't that because they're right now
worldwide.
I believe that the number three cell
phone manufacturer,
I think it's Samsung,
apple,
and then walk away,
but you can't buy Huawei phones in
America and I'm wondering.
Yeah,
we're scared of the Chinese taking over.
Are you going to try and get one of
these phones anyway?
I did try to get one,
but what I've found out is they're not,
um,
they're not set up for the US market.
The GSM phones and I'm on a CDMA
network,
but the GSM phones,
they using different bands.
They're not using all the same bands.
Like when you buy a phone from China,
even if it's for the UK,
they don't use.
So if you,
there's some places we would sacrifice
coverage.
Say if you bought a and if you are a
cell phone genius out there and you'll
listen to me butcher this.
I'm so sorry,
but this is all I got.
What's up?
Could you just use it with Wifi only and
not connected to the fuck would you do
that because you're in the Wifi.
Almost ended up talking about as a
phone.
I know,
but where's Wifi?
You driving your phone,
your Wifi when you're driving your car.
How are you doing that?
Time Warner has wifi all over la if they
have wifi problem with tracking you.
But yeah,
definitely 100 percent.
Okay.
So if you're driving in your car,
you could be on Wifi and have your cell
phone service shut off.
Cars also now have them built into their
thing too.
There's those are cellular.
Your cellular logic.
It was just a question,
couldn't you also.
But that's a cellular Wifi.
So you'd have to have a cellular
account.
So like who would be your cellular
provider?
Then you're just connecting your phone
to a Wifi thing and you're right,
that's a different thing.
BMW or Mercedes,
right?
So whatever that is would be a local
thing.
You'd have to be right next to your
fucking car.
You use your phone.
That's stupid.
What I'm saying is the problem with the.
This is what our article that I read
does explaining the problem from.
I think it was one of those tech sites,
but it was saying that in certain places
with limited coverage,
you probably would have no coverage with
one of these phones.
Whereas it would work.
Okay,
if you were in New York or in Los
Angeles or Chicago or something like
that,
but if you went to the boonies where you
might get,
if you have verizon,
you probably could be able to text your
friends or get a phone call out,
but you wouldn't be able to do that
would be a lot harder.
Yeah.
It's just not optimized for our
networks.
Well,
hopefully it'll change or not.
We're not just keeps quashing them,
but I wonder did the problem is I
believe they think walway is connected
with the communist government.
Yeah.
They're completely integrated,
so it's.
I mean,
the separation of business and
government over there is.
It's very sketchy,
right?
Yeah.
The fuck do I know?
I'm just.
I just wonder if there's a fear of Asian
success.
Yeah,
I mean how could that be though?
The Samsung.
Samsung is everywhere.
They're,
I mean,
they're going to come for everybody,
so they're coming for us right now.
It's only a matter of time.
You know,
who's they?
The people who want equality of outcome
for everyone.
Oh,
who are those people?
The people who are really into identity
politics.
Do you think,
wow,
I didn't really think that's what was
holding back Walway I thought it was the
government,
the government was worried about them
getting too much money and power,
but I guess if you're asking me in terms
of my,
my view on things and in my experience,
that's where I would take it.
So the equality of outcome people,
the reason why they're trying to keep
Asians or at least limit the number of
Asians in.
But does that have the opposite effect?
Doesn't that make Asians work even
harder?
And I mean if you keep them out of
Harvard,
they're just going to go to Yale,
keep Medicare doesn't have numbers like
that.
So at Caltech,
there're a lot of Asians there because
they don't,
uh,
they don't discriminate so they just
dominate.
So you use Caltech as a petri dish?
It can be like a controlled.
Yeah.
Hmm.
But what's wrong with that?
It's like,
but no,
no,
no.
The other thing,
like what's wrong with certain cultures
dominating?
I don't think there's anything wrong
with that.
I think,
well,
I mean if you're asking me in terms of
what people see as a problem,
I think because it looks as though other
groups are not getting a fair chance.
It doesn't make.
It doesn't make people feel good,
right?
Because it means that you're
acknowledging at some level that some
people are doing better than other
people and that makes some people
uncomfortable.
Right?
It's the participation trophy world,
the equality of outcome world.
Yeah.
That's exactly what it is.
Right?
But it's gone to a place where it
becomes indefensible,
so instead of raise trying to raise up
people whose scores are lower and them
any an equal
opportunity or take people from
impoverished areas with poor education
and give them more of a chance,
which is what affirmative action was
supposed to be about.
Yeah.
Instead of that,
you're doing it from the top down.
You're going to many of these people
that are doing good,
we've got to squash it,
will limit their ability,
but how could they do that in good
conscience?
That's what's crazy,
but did doing it from that perspective,
doing it like looking at a race that's
super successful,
that is also a minority and saying too
many of them.
Well that's the thing.
I mean I think these people do think
they're doing something good.
They're doing it for the better of
society and for these other groups.
I like to see it too.
Have you ever talked to someone about
it?
That's pro discrimination against
Asians?
I have,
after I wrote that column for the Globe
and Mail and number of people came out
of the woodwork to tell me how wrong I
was and there was some white,
some Asians do well to say don't let
yourself be used by the far right to
justify,
you know,
taking down other groups.
Oh,
that's an interesting way of looking at
it.
Yeah.
So that.
I mean that's one way that you could
look at it,
but
was that way possible to look at it?
That doesn't even make any sense.
You.
How would the far.
Right,
so the fire,
Rachel hold of the superiority of Asians
in academics
because there are other racial groups
that they don't like or I guess they
disliked more than they dislike Asians,
so they'll use Asians as a way to
justify discrimination against those
other groups.
I don't.
I don't really buy that,
but that's an argument I've heard the
arguments sucks.
I'd like to sit down with someone with
that argument.
That's a stupid argument.
That argument doesn't work.
It doesn't work.
What I find the most sad is there are
Asians who are totally fine and they
say,
I'm willing to give up my spot for
someone else because I think diversity
is important and I think that someone
who needs friends,
you need friends so bad you willing to
say that,
but that's a virtue signaling thing.
That's one of those.
I hope so.
I hope it's purchasing the.
It's not someone who actually thinks
that way.
They could actually think that way,
but the people cut their balls off and
killed themselves because they thought
the comment was coming in the spaceship
is behind it.
They thought that too.
People think all kinds of things.
They think all kinds of things.
Yeah,
and that is one of the main reasons why
I wanted to talk to you is that people
do think all kinds of things I want to,
I want,
you know,
I want to talk to neuroscientists,
figure out what's happening.
What is it?
Yeah.
Let's,
you were saying something about the
Google memo earlier though.
Yeah,
yes.
Yeah.
That's A.
I mean,
I had james on and you know,
he's kind of fucked now.
He doesn't really have a home.
He doesn't have a place to go.
And I mean in terms of like,
like politically,
politically or in terms of having a job.
I mean he's like almost hireable.
I mean,
uh,
I don't know if he's employed now,
but he was in this lawsuit with Google
and scientifically he has every point in
the.
I just don't know
if it's ever going to hold up in this
climate.
Yeah.
So I actually got a chance to talk to
james as part of.
So there's a podcast wrong speak that I
host with Jonathan Kay and our first
episode was actually about James to and
his saga and basically how,
what I took away from that whole thing,
I mean it's been almost a year now.
It's amazing how the media could not get
it right and I feel that they
intentionally smeared him.
It wasn't that people didn't understand
the science so that they very
intentionally said we don't like this.
We want to get clicks or we want to
basically sacrifices man for our agenda.
I agree with you and I don't think it's
just the media.
I think it was the CEO of.
Was it youtube that was saying that it
was promoting harmful gender
stereotypes?
Vp of Google put that statement out
there.
Other people.
Yeah,
but one of the,
one of the women that ran youtube was
talking about a two and the way she was
describing it was as if he was talking
about women being inferior and that's
not what he said or somebody said,
and not only that they neglected to to
promote the fact that it was at least a
page and a half of that memo was about
how to encourage women to be more active
in tech.
Yeah.
This was not an anti woman scream.
No,
no,
and I mean if you hear what he had to
save when I spoke with him,
he very much was for equality and very
much it was for men and women being
working together,
you know,
and it's not a misogynist.
I think it's crazy that that's the
narrative that continues to go on now.
Well,
the problem is he actually started.
He actually cited the studies that
showed why people choose different
professions,
why people gravitate towards different
activities in different professions
based on gender.
And these are actual studies.
So in inciting those studies,
he cited something that's contrary to
this promoted narrative and that's where
he was shot down.
Hence the title of your podcast.
He did wrong.
Speak,
right?
Yeah.
And the thing is,
the most important aspect of the podcast
is that the things that people are
saying,
there's some truth to it.
It's not just crazy loopy ideas,
right?
There's,
there's truth to it.
But for some reason we still can't say
it.
And why is that?
I don't know why that is.
But the problem with denial of any facts
is that the people that are opposing you
now have evidence that you're alone,
right?
Like one of the problems with the left
and this really radical progressive
behavior that's in denial of science is
now the right gets to look at the lab
and go,
look,
these people are their fucking mind.
Why do you trust him about abortion?
Why do you trust him about this?
Why do you trust them about climate
change?
Clearly there loons and this,
this is mean.
This is just weird toxic tribal
behavior.
Yeah,
because I mean,
how can you legitimately denied,
like you're saying,
men and women are different when you say
that people stop listening,
they do think you're a crazy person and
they miss the larger point because there
are some people who will look at that
and say,
okay,
men and women are different.
That must mean women are not competent.
So instead of having this more nuanced
argument or discussion about we can be
different,
but that doesn't mean women are in
competent.
They just simply say,
you want to say that men and women are
the same,
so we,
you know,
we're not even speaking at the same
level and in that case,
well it's so foolish and we are,
there's clearly differences between men
and women and there's clearly
differences inside genders.
I mean there's human beings very widely
and wildly and it's one of the more
interesting things about us.
I mean,
it's a good thing.
It's a fascinating thing because it's,
the whole thing has got to go like this.
It's got to move around.
And the only way it moves around as if
everybody's different.
If everybody just a block,
it's the same shape,
the same density,
the same size,
like what is that?
That's.
Well,
it's not just boring.
You're not going to have a competence
society.
It's not going to work like you need
soft and hard.
You need both.
You need something in between.
You need far extreme right to polarize
and activate the far extreme left.
I mean I really think you need a guy
like trump to get people to be more
politically active and more socially
active.
I think in many ways he does the left of
service by providing this like
ridiculous figurehead of what's possible
with ego and greed and and and right
wing gone a muck Steve Bannon's and the
breitbarts and all that.
Stuff like that.
Stuff empowers the other side and the
good thing about it is somewhere in the
middle is like a balanced healthy
society and hopefully we'll be able to
achieve that someday.
But I mean this is the argument always
is that you cannot have light without
dark and have good without evil and the
pendulum is gonna Swing back,
hopefully just waiting for that to
happen.
It always does,
it seems to always do that.
I just would hope that with the amount
of information that's available today
that we can look at the actual studies
that are being done on gender,
on sex,
on biology,
and don't look at it in terms of don't
quantify it in terms of the this side's
better.
That's it's better.
Just look at it.
What fascinating differences.
This is amazing and it's interesting and
there's a lot of dummies that are men
and there's a lot of dummies that are
women.
They're just dummies and it doesn't have
anything to do with one gender being
superior or one gender being inferior.
It's just human beings have a lot of
variability and there's a lot of
different things that a lot of inputs
and you developing and becoming a 30
year old person that happens to be
talking to this other 30 year old
person.
Your path to get to wherever you are.
There's so much going on.
There's influences in terms of your
environment,
your education,
your,
your life,
your family,
your loved ones,
your.
There's so much that leads to you being
who you are today and it's really
fascinating to study that,
but only if you're allowed to actually
look at it
and be honest with you because there's
no point otherwise if you're just going
to keep pumping out,
like from a research perspective,
you,
if you go in,
the only scientists are going to look at
this stuff now.
The people who know what they're going
to find in advance,
they're not going to publish anything
that's gonna upset the public.
So in my mind there was no point to even
do that kind of research because that's
not actually science what you're doing.
Yeah,
that's really crazy,
right?
That's where it gets really crazy or
you're not even allowed to do certain
kinds of research or if you are doing
it,
you're going to be categorized,
oh,
he's all right.
Or your,
you know,
you're conservative or you're a
whatever.
Whenever you are,
you're bad.
You're wrong.
Speak.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
And why did you decide to call your
podcast that?
I mean,
it's,
it's a throwback to Orwell,
obviously in 1984,
and this idea that by controlling
language we can control the government,
can control how people think and what
reality is.
And what I find interesting is with the
topics we covered.
So first episode we talked to James
Damore,
second episode we talked to Lindsay
Shepherd and looked at the whole what
happened at Wilfrid laurier university.
Um,
and then the third one is rapid onset
gender dysphoria.
So looking at this trend and adolescent
girls who come out as transgender even
though they've had no previous signs of
gender dysphoria.
And so with all of them,
these,
these issues are all super taboo and all
these people have been mobbed.
And in the case of rapid onset gender
dysphoria,
you see the parents who are being called
Trans phobic for questioning is my
daughter really trends,
you know,
we're just trying to get at the truth.
Really.
We're trying to understand,
you know,
why is it we can't talk about these
things?
Why is it we're in such a situation now
that the,
the response to any sort of,
um,
unpopular idea is to be mobbed into
attack people and intimidate them and
shut the conversation down.
Like how do we stop that from happening?
Explained rapid onset gender dysphoria
because I'm not really aware of that.
So it's this phenomenon that's been
growing more recently.
How recently,
I'd probably say in the last 10 years
there's been a switch though before,
a referrals to gender clinics have kids
who are feeling that they are born the
opposite.
Sex was predominantly boys.
And then suddenly there's been this
explosion of girls.
And so when you talk to the parents,
um,
and it's interesting when,
when you listened to the episode that we
did,
their stories are so similar.
They're literally identical.
They,
their daughters have always been gender
typical.
So they're always very girly girls.
They've never been gender dysphoric.
They go through puberty,
they develop,
you know,
there's no problem there.
Then usually what happens is there's
some sort of Dunno educational session
at school or one of these girls,
their friends come out as trans.
And then the daughter says,
oh,
I want to be a boy.
And so if you take that child to a
professional like therapist,
the therapist has to affirm,
the therapist can question that.
And so you have these girls,
a lot of them have autism or they have
other mental health issues.
They're not getting treated for those
issues.
Instead they're being told,
okay,
if you want to transition will help you.
And like I said,
I'm not against adults transitioning.
I don't think it's anyone's place to
tell an adult what to do.
And I think transitioning can be
beneficial,
but you want this.
If someone transitions,
you want it to actually help them feel
better.
And for these girls,
if the issue is not even about gender,
it doesn't make sense for them to
transition
mother's rapid onset gender dysphoria.
Is this typically females?
Yeah,
almost all females.
What would,
what is the cause of that?
I think it's social contagion.
I think part of it is for some of these
girls they are a bit socially awkward
and so when they come out as
transgender,
suddenly everybody loves them and wants
to support them.
And I think as people should for trans
people,
because obviously it's a difficult thing
to go through,
but I think there's an aspect of it that
people aren't talking about that kids
are coming out as transgender just
because it gives them acceptance,
an extra reward.
There's a reward in terms of the
attention.
Right?
Yeah.
And also I think for girls,
I mean puberty is not a fun time.
Puberty's not a fun time for anybody,
but for God,
you didn't go through puberty.
Okay.
I did.
But I mean,
you know,
for like I love when people say,
well,
it's harder for guys.
Who the fuck would,
you know,
he never been a girl.
It's hard for everybody.
Everyone is kind of awkward and Lanky.
You know,
life is hard.
Life is weird.
You being a person being a finite
organism,
cleaning to a ball,
it's spinning a thousand miles an hour
hurling through infinity.
That's weird.
Life's weird.
And then the fact that your biology
changes and you get inundated with
hormones,
it's uh,
just the,
the life that we live and then adapting
to culture and trying to figure out how
to be accepted.
And I think that that certainly plays a
part,
this rapid onset gender dysphoria.
How is this being treated like in terms
of like how's this being accepted in
academia?
How's it being discussed in the
literature and what are the
recommendations for what to do about it
or to descriptions of what it is.
Well,
there's only been one study so far
that's been published because it is such
a new phenomenon and because it is so
hard to do this work because,
I mean people call it a myth pretty much
anything that counters the transgender
narrative is considered hate speech.
So as a researcher,
if you try to do any research on this
issue that goes against what trans
activists say is acceptable,
you know,
you're going to get into trouble.
So no one wants to touch it.
So there's been one study that did show,
you know,
with girls especially,
it's very much about being influenced by
friends within a peer group.
I think there's some crazy high number
in terms of the number of girls that
will come out as transgender one after
the other,
so it's real.
But I,
I mean I get why people find it,
some people find it threatening because
it suggests that maybe trans people
aren't really transgender,
you know,
maybe the way they feel isn't
legitimate,
but in terms of the way to treat there
are these parents are at our last.
I mean the,
the,
these girls are not getting treated for
the underlying condition.
There was one parent we spoke to,
he saw nine mental health professionals.
Every single one said that your
daughter's not transgender,
but they couldn't go on the record as
saying.
So I think only one went on the record
of saying so because they're terrified.
They're terrified of losing their job.
They're terrified of being attack.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
It's so interesting where you watched
the similarities between any group that
like is that feels that they're being
maligned or that are being very
defensive about their position and
trying to hold strong and aggressively
attacking people that are against it.
It in many ways this sort of behavior is
mirrored in the second amendment.
People like the people that are pro gun,
like if you tried any gun restrictions
or any gun legislation or any changes in
the laws of gun control,
they aggressively go after it.
They,
they,
they do whatever they can to keep things
the way they are now and show how much
positive benefits guns have and how,
how many people are saved by guns.
But it's this thing besides the gun,
take the gun out of it and it's this.
It's the defense of the idea.
It's like very committed.
Yeah,
they are.
They identify with being a person who's
a gun nut or a gun supporter of Second
Amendment,
you know,
freedom loving and I got a fucking eagle
on my back.
You know,
that kind of shit.
And it's like.
And this the same thing with trans
people.
Like anything against anything,
what you're saying,
this is impossible.
This thing that you're talking about,
this rapid onset gender dysphoria being
autistic people that is transphobic and
the and they get super hyper aggressive
about it.
Instead of saying,
Oh,
well,
whoever this person is,
if they're a trans person,
so saying,
well,
I am legitimately trans,
but his entire po entirely possible that
there's a broad spectrum of human
behavior and human thought and that some
of these people have a real issue and I
could see the reward,
especially in today's climate.
When you look at today's climate was
that would be an interesting study,
right?
If you look at the climate of today and
the support of trans people and the
attacking of people that are transphobic
and the the overwhelming social benefit
of supporting trans people and then you
look at the rapid onset gender dysphoria
and see if they match up what you were
saying.
Actually I.
The
majority of Trans People are not on
board with this whole across the board.
Everyone should just transition,
but I think it's.
It's another case of the vocal minority
saying shutting down.
Anyone who dares to disagree,
well,
some trans people get very upset if non
trans people talk about Trans people
were just hilarious.
Like what are we supposed to do?
Supposed to just shut our mouths and let
you just run things like shit,
I don't know what to do.
Like the Scarlett Johannsen things
fascinating.
She was going to play a trans woman in a
movie and people freaked out.
Trans Man,
sorry,
a trans man in a movie and people
freaked out that she is not trans and
she's.
She has this part,
you know,
that was the same thing that happened
with Jeffrey tambor.
Jeffrey tambor was accused of sexual
harassment by people in the set who are
trans,
who were also very upset that he was the
star of a television show that was about
trans people and he's not trans and they
were trans.
I get where people are coming from.
I do because you know,
they.
I think representation is important to
some extent and so I can understand if
you are of a group that isn't being
represented in the media,
how you would want that to change.
Yeah.
But you also looking at an alias actress
who would bring an incredible amount of
attention to your progressive project
and you know,
it may very well change the tone of the
way people accept trans people.
Like if it's portrayed in a positive
light,
it's entirely possible that it would
open up.
Like,
especially if people that are on the
fence,
it might open up their heart and they
make them look at things differently and
say,
oh,
okay,
I see where this woman wanted,
you know,
she,
she wanted to transition to be a man
because she was wired incorrectly or
wired to be a man.
I shouldn't even say it incorrectly.
Like maybe you could see her as a person
now instead of just as a subject for
debate or as a career I would have,
is not with your appointment with my
point with the tokenization of people.
So to say,
okay,
if this is a trans role,
we need to find a trans person.
Right.
You know,
same as with racial tokenization.
Like we need to have a certain quota so
we need to have this many number of
people that fit this.
That's my only issue because then people
look at it and say,
you only pick this person because of
their identity,
not because of what they brought to the
table.
True.
But I could argue against that.
If you go back and look and like John
Wayne when he played gingiss con,
like what in the fuck was that?
Well,
there's a bunch of those really goofy
ones like Charlie Chan.
Do you ever see the old school Charlie
Chan movies?
I think so.
I think we can find Charlie Chan.
It's fucking ridiculous.
I mean,
couldn't even get an Asian guy to play
Charlie Chan,
but the fuck is this.
Or maybe they didn't even.
They didn't even try to make John Wayne
look like he was Chinese.
You know?
I mean there was a lot of that going on.
You do you ever see that ad where you
see the native American?
Yeah,
there's,
there's the guy who played the.
Kathleen did that motherfucker doesn't
even look a little Chinese and he talked
like a real stereotypical,
like shitty Chinese accent.
It's a bit offensive.
Super Offensive.
Right?
But that was the sign of the Times.
And so what trans people would say,
it was like,
look,
this is the same goddamn thing.
This is just you're looking at in terms
of Chinese people were looking at in
terms of our people and you know,
we're not being represented
and you have someone playing us.
Do you remember that native American ad?
There was an ad where someone would
throw litter out of the car window and
the native American guy had a tear
running down his cheek.
I do remember that.
Yeah.
The Guy was Italian.
He wasn't even a little bit of American.
Will they do now?
Anybody listening?
Some people know because I didn't like,
I'm not a researcher.
I didn't.
I didn't go deep and investigate.
I would just read it.
I was like,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think for a lot of these issues at the
core,
there's something valuable there.
I do get the concern and I am empathic
for that,
but it's to the point now where it's
like every little thing.
Yeah.
Well people,
this is the outrage culture.
People were like super pumped to find
something that's outrageous and then
point fingers and attack and they love
it when people back down.
Oh,
they're so excited.
So like when scarlet Johannson backed
out of that movie,
everybody got so excited.
We did it.
Girls,
we've fucking got her,
you know,
and,
but when people don't back down,
they get,
they just give up or they get confused.
They don't know what to do,
but that's the thing I find when you
don't back down,
they go and they find someone else,
they'll leave you alone.
Do you see what happened to Anthony
Jeselnik?
No,
I didn't.
They're attacking Anthony Jeselnik.
They're attacking a bunch of people for
tweet jokes.
After James Gunn got fired.
You Know James Gunn is,
he's the guy who was the director of
Guardians of the galaxy.
Uh,
he had some really questionable tweets
that were jokes.
They're just,
he wrote some jokey joke things,
but it's like about pedophilia.
Like there was like a huge screen of
them copied and pasted.
Yeah.
They're fucking terrible.
The problem is they're not funny in the
end,
their jokes and they're really gross,
but should he be fired for that?
No,
he's just a shitty joke teller.
If you find out he's actually a
pedophile,
that's one thing,
but it's Disney in this.
Today's climate,
so then they find that Anthony Jeselnik,
the standup comedian has a bunch of also
offensive jokes and some of them about
pedophiles and so they go and try to
attack him and Anthony Jeselnik rights.
Looking through my twitter timeline.
Something along.
He said,
looking is like looking for a needle in
a needle store on customer appreciation
day.
So true waist,
his whole fucking thing is his
character.
Like Anthony Jeselnik in particular,
I'm friends with him.
His whole thing is being ruthless and
super offensive.
Like he had a show called the Jeselnik
offensive.
I mean that's what he does.
He set his character is he's an awful
person.
That's the character and so they just
gave up.
It's totally lost on people now,
right?
You can't.
You just can't say things,
period.
Well,
they're looking for people to back down
and they're looking for people to get
scared and then,
I mean,
this is fun.
It's fun to find a target and find a,
let's get him fired,
get her fired kicker tagger off that
movie.
It's fun for them because as you know,
Hashtag air quotes activist.
What they're doing is they're just
attacking and there's probably some good
out of it,
but look,
there's gotta be some good for sure.
Out of real monsters getting arrested,
right?
There's,
there's some good out of like the Harvey
Weinsteins and the bill cosby's the
world getting arrested and getting
busted and shutting down and we would
hope that other monsters in waiting
would not act out on their instincts
because of the fact they're worried
about the repercussions that you're
clearly seeing and that we would hope
that people that are behavior as a
culture shifts one way or another and
then it's gonna move as far away from
massage and he is possible and it's
whether it's through the threat of
incarceration or shame or whatever it is
that causes it to go the other way.
It's probably for the best as long as it
doesn't go as far as all men are pigs,
all men are creeps.
All men are trash and that's what we
were talking about earlier.
Like when it gets to that place,
you got to go,
well this is not.
This is not a good place to be.
Well also if there is an allegation that
that's taken at face value right away,
because we do see unfortunately that
some of these allegations are false.
Well,
it has to be this whole idea of believe
women.
Well,
okay,
but that was okay.
Does that mean don't believe men because
some women lie and some men lives.
What about individuals?
What about human beings?
So if we're going to be.
It's what we were talking about earlier,
like white power,
black power,
Brown power.
Well let's fucking human beings.
As soon as we stopped looking at human
beings as individuals and we just agree
that one group is good and one group is
bad.
You've got some real discrimination
problems.
Yeah.
Well you can't win in that way either
because you can't look whether you side
with believe all victims are.
I believe,
what is it?
I believe women or something like that,
if there's a Hashtag,
believe women believe so I believe
survivors or something like that,
right,
and then or if you say you want due
process and women lie and you know that
side of the equation,
I think even both sides are equally bad
because you're not getting at the truth
or also in this weird slippery thing
when it comes to human beings and truth
because it's so hard to tell who's
telling the truth.
If two people see something or you see a
car accident and one person says,
well,
this lady ran the red light and slammed
into the car,
and then the person right next to it
says,
no,
she didn't.
This other guy ran the red light and she
hit him and this.
There's a lot of subjectivity in terms
of like interpersonal relationships.
Well,
there's also a problem with just
describing things and language.
In reality.
It's hot.
I don't know if you're telling the
truth.
I don't know mean especially if it's
just like,
you know,
I,
I leave,
I go to the bathroom,
I come back and Jamie says she,
she just call me a piece of shit and
you're like,
no,
I didn't like,
okay,
well who's right?
I don't know.
I don't,
I literally don't have a mechanism to
detect who said what it is not possible.
Yeah.
So am I just going to believe women or
am I going to believe the individual or
am I going to try to like figure this
out?
Am I going to do my detective work?
Fuck.
It's very tricky.
So when you're dealing with some certain
accusations when it comes to human
beings like this,
Chris hardwick things,
a perfect example of that.
I mean he was just reinstated yesterday
by AMC and um,
yeah,
that's a weird one because she wrote
the,
it was an ex girlfriend that wrote
something about him.
Yeah.
I read that most clearly didn't tell the
truth about some aspects of their
relationship.
She cheated on him and that's why he got
rid of her or broke up with her and then
he or she also said he was just terrible
boyfriend and he did,
but then there's videos of her talking
about what an amazing boyfriend he was
while they were together,
about how we stayed with her in the
hospital and slept by her bed and it's
like,
and she's also.
She had a bunch of host of mental
illnesses that she described in their
video about like not being able to drive
down the street with the windows open
because she was worried that germs are
going to get in her car and some of
those she recovered from and some of
them she didn't like.
It's an.
There's another problem with people when
it comes to when they're talking about
things,
they might not even be lying.
They just might be.
They just might have a distorted
perception of reality.
That is another problem with human
beings when it comes to any sort of
interaction between two people,
especially after
breakup.
I think the way that a person can view
the time they spent with someone can
very much change based on their current
situation or how that breakup.
One hundred percent.
Yeah,
but on both sides.
The real problem though is what we were
saying is that human beings,
it's very difficult.
I can't read minds.
You can't read minds.
You can't look into memories.
So we're relying on a person's
description and then we have to rely on
what we know about them,
what,
how,
what we know about their ability to
describe things accurately,
what we know about their perceptions of
reality are delusions there,
there,
there.
Clarity.
So fucking super tricky.
Yeah.
I mean,
my rule of thumb,
what I would say to people is,
unless you know the two people,
I don't think you can ever really know
what happened.
So in that case of say you leave and
Jamie tells you,
I said something about you,
you're probably going to go with Jamie,
right?
Because you know him.
Sam is a little crazy.
I might.
I might go.
Yeah,
I mean it's for sure if I didn't know
you and Jamie told me you did something
fucked up,
I would side with Jane,
but even that's weird if I'm not there
or if I don't know.
If you say I didn't do anything,
I'm like,
well maybe one day you'll be my best
friend and maybe one day Jamie turned
out to be a fucking psycho.
I was like,
remember when we used to think was okay,
he's crazy,
but
that's the thing too.
I think sometimes with.
I do empathize with some women who say
if this happens to the men and people
say,
well that's a nice guy.
I know that guy.
That's my buddy.
I've known him forever,
but you didn't date him,
so how do you know?
You don't know,
right?
Yeah.
You don't know.
God Damn it.
It's fucking tricky.
You know,
if you ever seen that episode of black,
do you ever watch Black Mirror
one episode?
So everyone tells me how amazing this
show is and I think it is amazing.
But I saw one episode that really
freaked me out.
So.
No,
it was the one about.
It was actually about a boy who was a
pedophile and then he was being watched
and blackmailed creeped me out.
I didn't watch that one,
but there's one called crocodile.
Okay.
And it is easily the most disturbing
episode of a television show I've ever
watched in my life and it,
it has to do with technology that allows
people to read memories.
Okay.
And I'll leave it at that.
So no spoiler alerts here,
but until it is fucking dark stays with
you after this one.
Does this one's dark.
I mean,
I mean I can't,
I can't,
I will give too much away if I talk
about it.
But the concept is that you can,
they have a machine and they set this
machine up and through this machine they
can literally read your memories until
that happens.
We really don't know.
And you know,
there's been things in my life where I
looked back on it and I had a perception
and then I went to the place where I
grew up and I was like,
I don't remember it looking like this.
I don't remember this being so close.
Oh,
the streets right here,
this is where the house is.
Oh,
and then you have to kind of like remap
your memory.
So like,
okay,
we got to clean these memories up and
try to figure out what's accurate and
what's not.
But then this,
this,
I'm just talking about like this,
the neighborhood where I grew up in,
but what about your adding in emotions?
Then you add again,
painful emotions because breakups and
perhaps suicidal thoughts and time going
by also time.
Sure.
I mean it's been absolutely proven that
eye witness testimony is the least
accurate piece of evidence that any
investigator can ever use in terms of
like trying to figure out what happened
at the scene of a crime or anything
involving any sort of trauma.
It's fucking hard with people's minds.
Yeah,
and I mean when we look at say the issue
with me too in the sexual assault,
sexual harassment,
that I think also some people see this
and they think I want to help this
person so they might reinterpret their
situation a way to say,
you know,
I also want to help this person.
Well,
I think
there's clearly without doubt,
been a lot of unchecked sexual
harassment in the workplace.
Just I,
I've always said this and this is not to
say that men and women shouldn't work
together.
Now I'm not saying that any stretch,
I just want to get that of way really
quick,
but when men and women do work together,
they're around each other all day and
people are sexually attracted to each
other and
men are gross and it's just like this
guy that I was having this conversation
with today,
we're talking about that.
I was like,
could you imagine being a girl and
working in an office and God's trying to
fuck you all the time and there was
saying stupid shit to you when you try
and get coffee and like we were talking
about gay guys and he was saying like,
do you ever.
When he was in the military,
would you have a problem with gay
people?
And it was really funny.
He goes,
he goes,
I would want to see if I was working
with a gay guy,
I'd want them to like me because that
way he tried to impress me and he'd do
his job better and he'd be real nice to
me and we were laughing about it,
but it was like,
okay,
that's true,
but if you run a gay guy that was always
trying to fuck you and like maybe
touched your ass when you bent over to
pick up some paper or something like
that,
like that would get real annoying and if
your job relied on this guy liking you
and approving you,
which a lot of women's jobs rely on,
creeps liking them and approving it gets
fucking disgusting.
That's the reality that many women have
lived with for decades.
I know that.
Yeah,
this is.
This is going to shift.
I'm hoping.
I'm hoping that the.
Even with the,
the,
the far reaching aspects of it were all
men are trash.
I'm hoping it's the Ty's gonna just sort
of settle back in and it's going to,
instead of being over this way,
it's going to come back over this way
and just balance out in the middle of a
little bit and we'll get a better
understanding of each other.
Yeah,
that's my hope too,
and I mean I,
I hope that there's not so much damage
done that's,
you know,
fixable at that point because of damage.
Well,
that you will see.
I feel men nowadays are terrified
interact with women,
especially in the workplace.
I think you should be careful anyway.
I think we're all way too casual about
getting intimate with people and I've
been guilty of it myself and my life at
many times,
but I think you should get to know
people a little bit better.
The promise people are horny and they're
like,
ah,
I get it.
I get you.
Oh you gave me,
hey,
let's do this.
You know,
and that's,
that's a real problem.
And then you hook up with crazy people
or you have to keep working with them
after.
Yeah.
That's even worse.
People that have inter office
relationships,
I know,
I know people who work in offices where
it's tricky,
forbidden,
like you're not allowed,
and then and then I'm like,
well,
okay,
but what if you fall in love with
someone in the office or if they're the
perfect person for you got to quit your
job.
Yeah.
I don't like businesses imposing that.
I think people should be able to make
those decisions be tricky.
Decision never date anybody at work and
I say that well,
but I don't know.
Married?
No,
not married.
Okay.
You have a boyfriend and no.
What if you met a guy that you worked
with and he was fucking amazing and he
was single and you're single and you
guys just got along great and he was
respectful and he's intelligent.
He's funny and he's interesting and you
liked doing things with them.
There are lots of men in this world.
Who the fuck out of here?
This is not.
That's not true.
There are so many men in this world.
Why is it this one person work with is
the only one who's going to be a match
for me.
He's the only one you've ever met.
It's like that.
I don't think so.
I mean,
but the thing is I'm very career
oriented,
so that could be part of why in my mind.
Well that's Joel.
That's a racist.
It's racist to say that Asians are
determined,
but in,
in that way,
I guess I'm a little bit more risk
averse.
I'm not gonna jeopardize potentially
jeopardize my career over a person that
I meet that I like.
What if he was wanting to quit his job?
Well
then he just did what we could talk,
but we,
I'd be like,
you're gonna you're gonna quit your job
for a woman.
I don't know.
You fucking loser.
What are you gonna do if we have kids?
Yeah,
yeah.
Um,
I see both sides,
but then I see,
okay,
now imagine being a woman who works in
the office with this guy who's in love
with this woman.
And then they have a relationship and
then all of a sudden her career starts
doing a little bit better.
That's the thing.
I know other women will.
Women like me say,
well wait,
we're not sleeping with people to get to
the top.
Is that fair?
Well,
that is the world of the actress.
It is and that is the world of the
casting couch and this is the seat.
This is the not so secret aspect of the
casting couch that many,
many,
many people are aware of is that these
women,
fuck some of these men and we're not
talking about rape.
We're talking about women who chose to
engage in willing full sex with people
who were fractional.
Yes,
transactional stuff.
Great.
Great way to put it.
There's a lot of women who I know who
are actresses who were approached for by
some certain types of men who were
producers or executives in certain ways
and they've said no,
and then girls that they know said yes
and their careers advanced.
Yeah,
and this was a thing where people were
aware of it.
It's,
there's a power dynamic that exists when
there's a boss and then there's an
underling is a person who's working for
that boss and whether it's a a producer
and an actress or whether it's a CEO and
an employee,
when they engage in some sort of a
transactional sexual relationship that
makes everyone fucking uncomfortable.
Yeah,
but how do you stop that you think?
Do you think it's the industry's job or
where do you weed that out?
I think corporations pretty much across
the board now,
just fire people when they do that.
There was a recent CEO of some large
high profile company who had a step down
because he was involved in a consensual
sexual relationship with somebody.
Do you remember who that was?
It was real big.
Something super recent,
but it was.
There was no crime,
but it was consensual sexual
relationship with someone who worked for
him.
Was it Intel?
Intel's.
Yeah,
that people.
They're around each other all day long.
I like you.
Think about it.
If you go home,
say if you work eight hours a day and it
takes you an hour to drive to work an
hour,
drive home,
that's fucking 10 hours and nobody eight
hours a day.
If you really want to make it right,
you were nine and 10,
so it's like half the day's gone.
You get home,
you're exhausted,
you know your husband's exhausts,
you're staring each other,
you're together like three or four
hours.
You have a meal,
you go to sleep,
you get up in the morning,
you'd go do it again.
You're with those people at work more
than you're even with the people that
you live with,
you know that's really,
and that's your waking hours.
By the time you get home,
you fucking tired and if you go to the
gym afterwards,
we'll.
There's an hour and a half gone there.
You might see each other for an hour a
night now,
and especially if people are single,
I mean obviously it's a little bit
easier for that to happen as well.
Yeah.
It becomes a big part of your social
interaction mean how many people there.
Their social circle is primarily the
people that they work with.
Real common,
right?
So,
I mean,
I think if it's a consensual
relationship,
there shouldn't be anything wrong there,
but I can see how in this climate there
are all these other ways of looking at
it being imposed on it.
So is that really consensual?
If it's someone who is your boss,
but then imagine say if you and Jamie
work together.
Okay.
And you guys had a consensual sexual
relationship and you both were on the
same level.
You both in does not.
It's not like anybody has any power,
but then you break up,
you know,
and then Jamie comes over to me,
he's like a fucking asshole connection
and then you come to me and you know,
like Jamie though he looks like a good
guy,
but when you start dating him,
he's a fucking selfish prick.
And then leave that at home.
Dad.
Well it's definitely becomes a problem
in the workforce when you,
you're,
you're not just friends.
Friends is fine,
but when you start having sex with each
other,
that's when things get crazy.
You know?
Very few people are able to separate sex
and emotions with friendship.
Very,
very few people.
That's probably.
That's one of the things that's
admirable,
but these people that are willing to
have these open relationships,
it's like,
whoa.
Like you can.
I know guys like hang out with other
guys who fuck their girlfriend.
I'm like,
Jesus,
you're a better man than me.
Well,
some of them like that though.
Like if they're masochistic,
they liked the idea of they're a woman
being having sex with another guy.
What you didn't want to use the word
Cook.
I like how you went with masochistic.
I guess that's a technical term.
Two,
we can call them cooks.
Cook is compromised word though,
isn't it?
There's a whole other stuff that comes
with that.
Yeah,
it gets squirrely.
I thought it always meant that it.
It always meant cuckold like you want to
watch men have sex with your wife,
but then it got to where.
What is it?
What is what?
The.
What is the Beta male?
The Beta male,
but there's so many different versions
of it now.
It's become really freely tossed around
like a beach ball at a concert is
throwing cukor around these days.
That's fine if that's what you're into.
No judgment there.
Yeah.
It's into being cuckolded yeah.
If that's what you're into.
Good luck with that.
Okay.
Cook a man who is desperate for
acceptance,
approval,
and affection from women.
Oh,
now it's different.
This desperation has lead to the
compromise of his beliefs and values to
desecration of his dignity and self
worth and this inability to stand up for
himself.
This four Chan,
right?
This and what he deserves as a human
being.
Example,
loyalty,
fidelity,
and honesty in a romantic relationship.
Okay.
Look at it.
Look at the example they gave.
Hold on a second.
I know John's always wanted a
girlfriend,
but since him and Mary started dating,
he's become a cook.
She spends all of his money and flirts
openly without openly with other men.
I can tell it bothers him,
but he's so afraid of losing her that he
doesn't say anything.
That's a cook.
Sounds like a male feminist also.
I can't believe you went there.
I don't.
Yeah.
That male feminist thing.
I've,
I've known a few that were real creeps
that were fake creeps,
you know,
they're like on the side,
they,
what they were doing was there
there
posturing as an alternative to these men
who don't want monogamous relationships
or would break the woman's heart or not
willing to compromise and bend to the
will of the woman and that they put
these women on a platform and worship
these women and I am the alternative and
I'm the powerful alternative and these
men are assholes,
and then they try to shit on those men
and take the,
but all it does is make those men appear
even more attractive to these women.
Secretly.
These men,
these feminists men and these women have
these weird relationships where it
doesn't work and they're never sexual or
sexual.
The women aren't really sexually
attracted to them,
so they withhold sex and it just.
It gets super weird.
Obviously.
I just generalized a lot about a giant
group of people's relationships,
but what I've seen,
it's just
it's they,
they don't run fast.
They can't pick things up.
They're not attractive,
so they tried it.
They're a little weasels.
They're trying to find another way in.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think men who,
not all men who call themselves
feminists are male feminists,
so in that I think men who ascribed to
women being equal at,
that's a good thing and I think a lot of
guys will say,
yeah,
I'm feminists because they think that's
the right thing to do.
That's the socially acceptable thing and
that's the way we should be.
But then the ones who run around and
say,
you know,
really,
really push it and make that their
identity and really sell themselves as
male feminists.
Those were the guys I have an issue with
because like you said,
they're sneaky and they know what
they're doing.
They're not being honest.
Well,
you can almost always tell you,
you see them,
you know,
there they're a type,
they're just,
they're an unattractive type.
They're not attractive to women.
And to try to figure out a way like,
how am I going to do this?
What's it going to be the way you've got
to figure out a way to stand out.
This is the way I'm going to just what?
What are these women want to hear?
They want to hear that.
I'm going to say that egalitarian.
Great.
You know,
someone who believes in equality is
great,
but as soon as you establish your
proclaiming yourself to be more
interested in the opposite gender and
more supportive of them,
then males and even though you are a
male,
hm.
That should be a red flag.
That's a giant red flag.
You should be into humans.
I like people.
I like people I like.
I'm gay.
Like I'm straight.
I like people.
I like when they're Nice,
nice to me.
I'm nice to you.
That's what I like.
I don't want you to get discriminated
against in any way,
shape or form,
but I don't want to pretend that one
group is better than other groups except
Asians when it comes to Harvard.
The crazy thing is with these guys
though,
you see there's been a trend where they
actually have a lot to hide and they
usually are misogynistic and they
usually do abuse.
Women was the scary thing.
I think what happens is there's a
certain amount of resentment that from
living this fake life and having these
fake beliefs and doing so just to get
through the approval of women,
you know,
and then when it doesn't work out,
there's anger,
resentment,
and this is just.
I think some guys put it on because it's
a way of overcompensating for their own
guilt.
Yeah,
that's true too.
Probably.
Yeah.
There's probably a lot of different
reasons why men become feminists and
very few of them are good unless they're
just.
Their idea of what it means is different
than my idea what it means.
My idea.
It means a little bit,
that little sneaky fuck.
That's my idea.
You know when I.
Because I've just seen so many of them,
it's like,
look,
I'm sure some bank robbers are really
romantic,
interesting poets who just decide this
is a great way to make money.
There's got to be one,
you know,
but most of them are fucking criminals.
Right.
And this is like how I feel about male
feminists.
Like I'm sure there's a bunch of them
out there that are really good guys and
maybe through the influence of the
people that have been around,
they've chosen to identify as a male
feminist and this seems to be a good way
to show that they support women and even
if they have to support women over men,
look at women have been fucked over for
so long.
I'm more than willing to do that and
they do it with good intentions.
That's entirely possible,
but a lot of it are creepy little dudes
that are trying to get laid and they
they're not attractive to women,
so they try to figure out a way to
become attractive to women and they
don't have the confidence to just go,
well,
aren't we all equal?
Aren't we all just all humans are.
We're all different.
We're working on yourself to make
yourself more attractive to it instead
of deceiving them.
One of my all time favorite tweets that
I read was the guy saying,
I'm not going to describe myself as a
feminist until women tell me that I'm
doing feminism correctly.
He's like more feminist than regular
feminists.
He's like,
so feminist,
you can't be a feminist to women.
Tell me I'm a feminist mistress,
Mr [inaudible],
please tell me.
He's.
That dude has got a ball gag on right
now.
He's like tightening a down.
He's putting himself in the shack also,
but then there's women like that too.
There's women that pretend to be one of
the guys like that girl is always the
one of the guy's girl it though other
guys can tell when a male,
when a guy's not sincere about being a
male feminist and the same with girls
can tell.
Oh yeah,
you know the big red flag with girls,
girls who don't have girlfriends,
they're just friends with guys.
I get along with guys better.
Yeah,
but you do.
I had a friend of mine who's,
who's dating a girl like that and she.
All she had was male friends.
I was like,
dude,
I'm like,
get out now.
Like this is not gonna work.
So tell me what does that mean?
Girls don't like?
Her girls don't trust or you can't find
any girls.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
That is crazy.
I'm not saying you shouldn't have some
guy friends,
but all your friends are guys.
Yeah,
that's a red flag.
No,
I would agree with that.
And any guy,
you have a straight guy and all his
friends are girls know a fuck is
happening.
Right?
We just don't get along with guys.
Guys are assholes.
I don't like the where they talk about
women.
Oh,
okay.
All of them.
All of them do.
Come on.
Where are you hanging out dude?
You don't like any guys.
Seems Weird.
So what did your friend do?
Oh,
he got fucked around on.
Yeah,
she was fucking all those guys.
I was going to say,
of course mean the writing's on the
wall.
Yeah.
It was ugly to the way it went down.
It's like woo.
But that's how it is.
People.
People are always trying to find their
way in like,
what's what's,
what's my way to get the most
acceptance,
my way to get the most happiness my way.
And I mean,
it's fairly unrelated,
but not necessarily to what we're
talking about,
about gender dysphoria,
about some people choosing that as a
path to get a lot of attention.
I mean,
I think there's many things that people
do to get a lot of attention.
There's things that people do to stand
out as typically unique,
right?
Like dye their hair pink or purple or
blue or wear certain things or do
certain piercings and just things that
people do to like get attention and fit
in and find their niche and just do
something where it makes them feel like
they have some clout in this community
of humans.
Yeah.
It helps them find other people too who
are like them.
Yeah.
And also like,
it's,
they're signaling to each other,
we're all equal.
We're,
or we're all similar.
We're all,
we're all in this kind of clan.
We're outsiders,
you know,
it's fascinating.
And I'm all for that.
I'm all for people finding each other
and self expression.
It's only when it is having negative
implications for other people,
that's when it's a problem.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
That's,
yeah.
When,
when it's not just a bunch of people
finding each other,
but a bunch of people looking at the
other people and attacking them for not
being similar,
but that's one of the things people do
to sort of affirm their identity,
right?
You attack the people that oppose that
identity or
people that are different to people need
to do that though.
I wish they didn't,
but they do so often
wonder like objectively,
if you were from another planet and you
were watching these patterns take place.
Here you go,
wow.
This creepy little organism like this
weird thing that it does.
Yeah.
Going back to the transgender,
uh,
bullying.
I guess my issue with,
uh,
with all of that intimidation is the
fact that these kids are not getting the
help that they need.
And so if we look at something like I
was saying earlier about if it's a
little boy who says he's a girl,
he's likely going to grow up to be a gay
man.
You can't say that now.
And so all of the scientific research
suggests that all the studies ever done
suggest that.
But you can't say that because it really
upsets transgender activists and so you
have all these children now are
transitioning who I think in five,
10 years are going to regret it.
Isn't this sort of similar to what we're
talking about earlier is that
historically
trans people have been so discriminated
against that it shifted so hard the
other way that it's gone the other way,
like just when we were talking about in
terms of sexism and harassment in the
workplace and sexual harassment and
rape,
so was so one sided that now it's
pushing the opposite way.
Like I read a tweet once by this woman
had said,
here's an unpopular opinion,
and she was an editor of a magazine.
Sure.
Here's an unpopular opinion.
I'm not even remotely concerned with men
being falsely accused of sexual
harassment or assault and she was
attacked.
Bret Weinstein retweeted it and pointed
out how wrong this idea was and how
crazy it is to to take allies who are
falsely accused of sexual harassment or
assault and not being concerned about
that.
Like you're,
you're only concerned with your own
gender and this is a.
This is a perfect example of an
intelligent person that's thinking in
this really crazy,
discriminatory way because in her mind,
her team had been fucked over so many
times that it's time to fuck over that
other team.
If we lose a couple of people,
hey,
we shoot some drones into some apartment
buildings and a few civilians die.
At least we got the terrorists.
Yeah,
and I mean I understand
that like the anger that comes with
that.
I think for the people who were the most
militant,
so not to say that have this particular
person,
but I think of women in particular who
are the most militant about this
movement.
I think they really just have been hurt
badly by men and it's a way for them to
express that,
but you can't say that no.
These women that are angry about men,
that they've been hurt by men,
so now they discriminate against large
groups of men because of that pain.
If you do that,
like you're.
You're a self hate or your.
Yeah,
internalized misogyny,
which is sad.
I mean,
but you can't actually argue with it.
Where does this balance out though?
Does it balance out to a point in our
children's future,
our children's Children's future where
this is no longer a concern,
like cannibalism is no longer a concern
or a very,
very slight concern where it's an
aberration,
where it's a very,
very rare thing.
I mean is that's the ultimate goal,
right?
Is that we reach a point in our society
where we do not care if someone's gay,
we got care.
If you're a girl,
we do not care if you're a boy and we're
not mad if you're not attracted to us or
I mean that would be a wonderful thing,
right?
If we get to a point where people are
just comfortable in their own skin,
you mean this craziness,
like where is it eventually going to
leave?
Yes.
I mean culturally across the board,
whether it's male versus female,
whether it's transverse a straight,
all of this gay versus straight.
Whether it's progressive versus
conservative.
I would love it if we got to this point
with all this chaos and calamity and
arguing back and forth.
It would be fantastic if we can get to a
balance point.
Yeah.
No,
I agree and I do think we're coming up
to that point because more and more I
see people are saying that they're not
okay with this in terms of the things I
write about.
People reach out to me and say,
you know what?
I'm so glad you said that.
I agree with you.
Even the response to wrong speak.
I really thought that people were going
to lose their minds in terms of the
things that we said,
but you know,
it's been very positive feedback.
So I think more people then you might
think are actually on board with,
you know,
wanting to come to a middle ground and
they're not okay with this.
The extreme craziness that we're seeing.
So I think that's a good sign.
It's just a matter of waiting it out.
I hope you're right.
And I hope that we understand why things
get extreme and that as human beings we
can look at it with compassion and say
like you were saying like women that are
so angry against men,
it's not just because for no reason
something had to happen to them.
Like I had a friend and who's not an
attractive man,
and over the time that I knew him,
he became more and more resentful to
women to the point where he would just
openly say fucked up misogynistic
things about women.
And it was weird to watch,
but it was,
it was one of those things where I was
like,
oh,
I see he associates women with paint in.
He associates them with just wanting his
money or trying to fuck him over and
this is his perception.
This is how he looks at women.
Like,
oh,
okay,
I get it.
Which is sad,
you know?
And in that case,
women obviously not all women are like
that.
Just like not all men are the men that
these women have encountered in life.
And you can't generalize from one person
to everybody.
No,
you can't.
But when we look at it with compassion,
I mean the hopefully the healthy people,
the people that aren't in that state of
anger and resentment,
that they look at it with compassion.
They go,
oh,
okay,
I see why this woman would write that
tweet.
She's met a bunch of fucked up shitty
dudes,
probably male feminists,
right?
Yeah.
And that she doesn't need to be mobbed
over her tweet either
trust.
No men.
Yeah,
or man.
Yeah.
That kind of shit.
It's like,
okay,
I get,
I get where that's from.
I just think there's entirely too much
conflict out there,
but
you know,
I think our society almost thrives on
it.
I would say the media definitely thrives
on it because if you're not angry and
upset about something,
what are people going to do mean?
Look at twitter,
social media to facebook's the best
because facebook,
those assholes are allowed to write
fucking forever wraps,
paragraphs of bullshit,
like swear.
Do they have jobs?
Some of these people I click on,
the more you click on the more thing and
then there's way more,
way too much.
I think there's just going to be a two
lines,
but it's like six pages.
Yeah.
I think that,
that,
that is a real problem and I think one
of the more unique things about twitter
is that it limited you to 140 characters
and then people complained.
So they gave you to 80.
No,
that's too much.
Sometimes I can't read all that.
Sorry.
It was.
Well,
as a comic,
1:40
was great because it made you really,
um,
it made you really invest in the economy
of words.
You really had to make sure that you got
your point out as quickly as possible.
It's great for joke writing because you
can just set a Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh
Duh Duh Duh Duh.
It's the,
it's a good way to like really trim down
the fat and your jokes,
but it's not a good way to express
ideas.
And that's one of the good things about
twitter is they have this thing where
you can reply to your tweet and then
reply to that,
reply to that thread.
And they all fit in together.
I liked that,
but I don't like it sometimes because
sometimes people just fucking drone on.
Um,
and on and on.
And this,
you know,
this is a first draft to edit this shit.
Bitch is too much nonsense in there.
You don't get that with your dms to
that.
People just send you a massive block of.
I don't read them.
I've,
I barely skim through my day.
I can't.
I follow too many people.
One of the good is I get a
lot of interesting things in my feed.
One of the bad things.
I'll get 500 dms a day.
I can't do that.
I saw someone wrote a tweet that said
if,
if my,
if you don't like write two sentences
for the DM,
I'm not going to read it.
And that was their pin tweet.
Wow.
That's aggressive.
I read as many as I can.
I just can't read them all.
There's no way.
Yeah.
It just,
it's like you can't reply to everybody
either.
Like people say,
welcome your reply to my app mentions I
can't.
Yeah.
And you can't like,
like all of their stuff either.
No,
it's too many.
It's too many boss.
I don't want to read people's stuff.
It's just I don't have.
You don't have the time.
And also if you're running the risk of
encountering too much negativity and and
then also things that you disagree with
that you want to like,
oh,
I should say that's bullshit.
That's not true.
I'm going to tell this guy.
This is what actually happened.
Yeah.
You don't even know history.
I don't want to do that.
I don't want to argue with people about
random facts or science or anything.
I'll look at it and I'm like,
okay,
this is.
But you've.
Have you been mobbed before?
You have what's been the worst?
Oh,
one of the big ones was a about a trans
fighter.
I remember that.
Yeah,
that was a hilarious one because I'm
like,
you guys can kiss my fucking ass.
You're out of your mind.
You guys are out of your mind.
If you think that a man who has been a
man for 30 years and has taken female
hormones for two is the same.
You put Brock Lesnar,
chop his dick off and put them in a
dress.
That guy's gonna Maul through the
women's heavyweight division like
nothing you've ever seen in your life
because we're built different and it's
just a fact and then they want to tries
to argue that it's crazy and there are.
There's certainly standouts in terms of
women who are a much more muscular,
higher bone density,
particularly African American women have
very high bone density,
but there's a different shape to their
hips.
There's A.
There's the size of the hands,
the size of the shoulders.
Things are different.
That also the imprinting of years and
years of testosterone.
It's just.
There was a great article by this.
I'm board certified endocrinologist who
went over all of the,
all the things that separate men from
women which should exclude them from
competing in combat sports against women
and this woman was called a transphobic
and she's a fucking endocrinologists
idiot.
She's talking about the science and
she's also talking about the science of.
One of the things they talk about is how
women,
you know,
or a trans woman.
Once they transitioned to being a woman
there basically biologically almost
exactly the same as woman.
She was like,
no,
not only that,
but the bone density is retained by
taking estrogen,
which is what the problem with women
when they have osteoporosis,
they they lose.
They're losing estrogen,
they lose bone mass.
Well,
the estrogen actually helps you retain
bone mass,
so when a man transitions to a woman and
then starts
taking estrogen,
it's actually helping retain the bone
mass that he would have lost by not
having testosterone,
and then on top of that reaction times
that Rita reaction times are several
tenths of a second faster in general for
women than they are for you or for men
rather than they are for even
professional athlete.
Women saw these.
All these variables that need to be
taken into consideration when you're
allowing someone to do a sport and that
we're not just talking about bike
racing,
we're not talking about something where
someone noncontact.
We're talking about the most contact.
We're talking about fucking fighting.
There's there's benefits that certain
people have.
There's,
there's physical attributes that pe,
there's variables inside the genders
right there.
There's some men that have gigantic
physical advantages over other men and
all of those are taking into you,
you,
there's no,
like even playing field when it comes to
even enter gender competition or,
or you know,
male versus male competition.
There's no real level playing field.
So the best we can do is say,
okay,
well you guys got to be the same weight.
You know what,
let's just make that,
make it the same weight and that's as
close as you can get.
But,
but even in that,
there's people that are just physically,
they're just,
they're just going to be better.
There's no,
there's no getting around it.
There's going to be better athletes.
There's,
they're going to have better genetics.
You know,
there's nothing you do about that.
But one thing we can do is we can keep
women from getting beaten up by men and,
and men who transitioned to being women.
And if you think that's fair,
you're fucking crazy and it's just not.
It just doesn't make any sense.
And the arguments for it are so shitty.
And so there are so riddled with
progressive speak that they're trying to
pretend that this is a woman.
Now,
this is not a woman.
This is a trans woman,
this is a male.
She has a y chromosome.
She transitioned to being a female.
Now she's a trans woman,
and if you choose to fight her and
you're a woman and you know that she's a
trans woman,
I'm totally fine with that.
But that was not what was going on here.
What was going on here was this woman
who used to be a man for 32 years,
transitioned to being a woman and it
didn't tell anybody and thought to
different women who thought they were
fighting a woman and got fucking smashed
watching it.
It was like watching a man fight a
woman.
That's what I was watching.
I was like,
this isn't like particularly.
She wasn't particularly skillful.
It wasn't like she had some unbelievable
background in judo,
like Rhonda Rousey or something like
that.
It wasn't that he would just literally
watching a former man beat up women who
never had the the benefit of 30 years
plus of testosterone in their body.
What do you think the solution should be
then?
I don't know,
but I was fascinated by watching the mob
come after me for that one.
I was like,
this is adorable.
What was fascinating about it was,
here's something I.
I mean,
I'm not a physio.
I'm not a real expert in physiology or
endocrinology,
but I'm a martial arts expert and I've
been doing it my whole life.
Like I know the difference I've.
I've trained with women world champions
and watch them get mauled by men who are
not very good.
It's just a fact,
especially when it comes to striking,
you know,
there's more of a gap in Jujitsu or the
gap rather closes in Jujitsu because
skill and technique take precedent over
physical strength,
but God dammit when it comes to
striking,
you could get a man who's been doing it
for six months but just happens to have
a lot of fast twitch muscle fiber and it
just knows how to hit things hard and he
he'll fuck a woman up.
It's not good,
especially when it comes to kickboxing
and kicking and punching.
There's so.
There's so many advantages and to to say
that those advantages are immediately
cut out of the picture.
As soon as you transitioned to being a
woman and within two years he should be
able to fight women in a cage and not
tell them,
you're a woman.
I was like,
this is insanity.
Yeah,
so that was the.
That was the big mob that came after me.
I think it's interesting that in this,
because it is pitting people who would
call themselves feminist against
transgender activists.
Basically women are being lost in the
mix,
so you can't say certain things like on
what planet would it be okay for someone
who is born male to fight a woman,
but in this case,
because this person who was born male
identifies as female,
you can't call that into question it and
it also,
there was a real problem in Texas,
the other way where they're there,
what they were doing as being prejudice
against trans people to the point where
they wouldn't let a girl transitioning
to being a boy wrestle with boys.
They made her wrestle with girls while
she was taking testosterone.
Like,
you guys are out of your fucking mind
like you.
You're not even recognizing that she
wants to compete with boys,
which is a disadvantage for her or him.
Now let him compete with boys because
this is a different thing,
but then even then a lot of boys are
saying,
well look,
I'm not taking testosterone.
I just have testosterone.
Would have her testosterone is higher
than my testosterone because she's
taking exogenous testosterone.
This is kind of crazy.
Like,
yeah,
it's.
There's a lot of new ground that's going
on here.
My concern as a martial arts expert is
when you are using ideology to push
this,
this progressive notion that,
you know,
a trans woman is exactly the same as a
woman and you're getting women beat the
fuck up because of it and this is what I
felt and this is what I saw and they
wouldn't have to be hard for like a year
or two,
but then it all went away.
What's the worst thing they said about
you?
I didn't read it.
I read a little bit of it and then I was
like,
oh,
I really didn't even hurt my feelings
because it was like,
this is so stupid.
It's like,
do you know a woman who's got a hand
that looks like that?
Find one,
find one.
Because if I took estrogen,
I'd still have these and that's not
fair.
It's just not.
I don't care.
I don't care what anybody says.
It's just not.
I mean,
even a woman with big hands,
they're not that big.
They're not like brock Lesnar's hands is
that there's a difference.
There's a fucking difference.
There's a difference in the shape of the
jaw,
the difference in.
So there's so many differences in men to
women and there's so many women that
used to be men that transition to being
women that are now dominating these
sports.
Are these women feel like they're being
fucked over like weightlifting.
There was this Australian weightlifter
who is a trans woman who's competing as
a woman and his fucking breaking records
left and right.
And everybody's like,
this is crazy.
She's an inspiration.
Yeah.
No,
she's a guy.
She used to be a guy and now she's
breaking these women's records.
Like,
what are we doing?
This is crazy.
Yeah.
But to play devil's advocate,
please do fox get beaten by Ashley Smith
because she sucks.
That's really what it is.
Ashley.
Evan Smith is good.
She's so good.
She listened.
There's a lot of women that would be a
lot of men and women who are not taking
anything,
who would beat a lot of men.
And it's happened.
I'm a Germane to random me who,
uh,
was a super high level.
Women's MMA fighter is a 145 pound world
title beat.
Holly Holm.
She fought a man and a kickboxing bout,
knocked him out.
It's because she's a fucking beast.
She's really good and really technical,
super strong and just much better than a
guy who wasn't on her level,
but she's just super exceptional.
But there's also women who fought men
who were world champions who got knocked
down,
who there was a woman from.
God Damn it,
she was a female boxer from Holland.
Her name escapes me right now.
Um,
she was,
she was a woman that they were always
trying to match her up with Christy
Martin back when Christy Martin,
the coal miner's daughter was a famous,
God dammit.
Why can't I remember her name?
But she was an elite female boxer and
she got knocked out by a man.
It was ugly.
And the guy,
she knocked out,
the guy who knocked her out really
wasn't very good.
He just climbed her on the John and
killed her.
But it was disturbing to watch,
but somehow wasn't disturbing with
Jermaine to random.
He knocked out the guy.
Then it was like,
yeah,
girl,
I'm the,
you can't,
you're always going to have people that
are higher level skill and Ashley Evan
Smith,
who's competed successfully in the UFC,
she's very tough and she beat Fox and
that this,
you know,
I'm not against fallon,
Fox fighting women that want to fight
her.
I'm not against that.
If they want.
I'm not against women fighting men to
want to do.
I'm not a man.
I'm not against people riding bulls.
I'm not against people bungee jumping.
I should be able to do whatever fuck you
want,
but don't pretend that you're exactly
the same as a biological woman.
Well,
why the fuck do we have tests?
Then what?
Why?
What is it?
What is a chromosome?
What our genetics,
what are,
what is it?
Is it all?
We're just going to give it all away for
ideology.
And what about women?
Like what is this idea of being
completely progressive and and looking
at things and promoting equality.
That's wonderful.
But are you promoting equality for
women?
Like what about the women?
What about a woman like you?
What about a woman who's a slight thin?
What do,
what are you supposed to do?
How much do you weigh?
I'm not going to tell you.
You're very sad.
Let's pretend you're in the hundred and
five pound weight class.
Do you feel like you can compete with
100,
five pound man and.
No,
that seems.
That seems ridiculous,
right?
Well,
it seems to me that we have to accept
the fact that there's some physical
differences when the consequences are
being gravely injured and this is what
martial arts are all about.
I'm trying to hurt you and I shouldn't
have natural physical advantages that
come from having a y chromosome and 30
plus years of testosterone in my body.
That just seems to be obvious to me and
I didn't understand why,
but that was a hill that I was ready to
die on.
I was like,
you guys can fuck off.
Good for you for that,
but you see that they've kind of left
you alone now,
right?
Because I do this because I [inaudible]
I can say things like this about it and
I think because it makes sense because
when other people hear about it that are
rational people,
they go,
what?
What's happening?
Wait a minute,
that's a guy.
She was a guy for 30 years.
Like,
that's not right.
And the vast majority of people who even
support trans rights,
including friends of mine who are trans
or with me on this,
they're like,
yeah,
that's crazy.
Have you heard the term turf?
Uh,
my surf and turf
terp no.
Turf is in t e R,
F is trans.
Exclusionary.
Radical feminist.
So this is a new slur that's being used
against women who will say trans women
or not women because they were not born
women,
trans exclusionary,
radical feminist
kind of be a turf in this situation
because you are advocating for women and
the safety of women and saying that
people who are born male but identify as
female are not the same as people who
are born female.
Yes.
But that doesn't mean that I'm
discriminatory.
No,
it's a word that they use to try and
discredit you.
Good luck,
have fun with that.
I don't care see this problem,
but the thing about this is I don't care
because I really don't have any hate in
my heart and I don't have any
discrimination in my heart like I don't
think most of us do.
Well,
I speak for everybody.
Some do,
but
some do.
I'm sure.
I'm sure if you were Tryna look,
if you have a thousand people and 100 of
those people are a fucking asshole to
you.
It's gonna feel like a lot of people.
Right?
So if you're a trans person and you're,
you're.
I mean,
I've seen horrific things written to
trans people online.
I've seen it,
I've seen,
I understand that it's real
discrimination,
but I understand that you have to
understand,
you have to appreciate who your actual
allies and people who are rational
people who actually care about you and
who disagree with you.
On one very particular thing,
and this is the only place where I
disagree,
it's combat sports and it's because it's
my area of expertise.
I've been doing it since I was a kid.
Like you can't tell me that there.
There's not differences.
I've watched men and women fight my
whole life.
I know there's a difference and I know
that from talking to endocrinologist and
people who are experts in the human
anatomy,
that there's just physiological
differences that are insurmountable.
You just are.
I've seen men and women hit the bag.
It's a very different thing.
Yeah,
I mean I get where people are coming
from,
the people who are upset by this because
I think by acknowledging someone that
someone was not born the sex that they
identify as.
It's almost like saying,
pointing out to them that they're
different,
but they are different.
They are different.
But I can see how that can be upsetting
for someone who identifies as the
opposite sex.
Yeah.
You know what?
I can see how it's upsetting.
If you're short and you want to identify
as being tall.
You know what?
If I wanted to pretend that I was seven
feet tall and you'd be like,
Joe,
your five eight,
like,
are you an asshole?
Why are you saying I'm a five eight?
But you are.
So if I say you're a trans woman,
which means you're a born a man,
you have a y chromosome,
like where's you're a piece of Shit,
how you point that out,
but that's what you are.
It's not that you're negative or you are
people who are dwarves are is that.
Is it evil to say that a dwarf is a
dwarf or a little person and whatever,
whatever phrase you want to use,
are we supposed to acknowledge that
there is an issue,
like if someone is born with a handicap,
are you supposed to.
Is that a fact?
Are you allowed to discuss it as a fact
if you have autism,
my allowed to bring up the fact that you
are on the spectrum or am I supposed to
ignore it?
Yeah.
Is it discrimination?
If you talk about reality,
if someone has a deformity,
are you allowed to discuss it or is it
discrimination to discuss reality
because what are we doing with our
language?
What are we doing with the way we
describe the actual things that are that
exist in the world and if we're not
describing them in accurate terms
because we're trying to somehow another
stop people from getting hurt feelings,
what are these feelings based on these
delusional perceptions of reality and
why are we reinforcing these delusional
perceptions of reality?
Because it seems to me that this kind of
language in this kind of exclusionary
th,
the,
the inability
to use certain words and the inability
to describe things accurately,
correctly,
and in many cases scientifically it
hurts everybody.
Yeah,
I agree with that.
I don't think facts themselves are
hateful.
I think people who use facts to justify
discrimination,
that's where the problem is and that's
where the efforts should be going
because when you start to deny facts,
where does that leave you?
Where do you draw the line in that case?
Absolutely,
but I think it's,
there's something that's kind of cool
about it,
that there are trans people and what's
cool about it is that the world is
weird.
You know,
and I'm,
I'm not happy that they get a lot of
hate,
but I'm kinda happy that they exist.
I wish they could just be women.
I wish you could just hit a switch and
you really wish you were born a woman.
Bam,
you're a woman.
But I suspect that even if you could do
that,
some people would rather just be trans.
Some people would look like there's a
lot of people that I know that are trans
and also have Dick's.
Yeah.
And they want to keep the deck.
And they're like,
okay,
like what's going on here?
And you,
you know,
that you're transphobic if you're a
straight heterosexual male and you're
not willing to date a trans woman with a
Dick,
but you know what it is,
it's actually a sexual preference for
four men who will date trans women who
were.
It's retaining their penis.
That's what it's called,
the literature.
They decide not to get surgery.
It's actually a particular sexual
preference for the people that are
attracted to that particular trans guy
or morph affilia.
Whoa.
Someone told Jim Norton.
I'm nothing wrong with that either.
No,
nothing,
nothing what either do what you do,
but this is the thing,
the difference between a man and a
woman,
a trans man,
a trans woman,
and then someone who could actually be a
woman who transitions.
I think we're going to get to a point
within whether it's 100 years or 500
years where we can use things like the
future version of crispr or whatever
comes down the line next.
Some scientific innovation that's going
to allow people to literally transition.
Yeah,
I think it's gonna happen and when that
happens,
I suspect they're going to say that word
again.
What was the one guy named Andrew?
More fulfilling?
It's going to be a bunch of those.
It's going to be a bunch of people like,
man,
I'd rather just stay at chick with a
Dick.
I'll take it.
Yeah.
Well,
again,
Andrew more fulfilling is the preference
for male to female people who have
retained their penis.
Fucking go for it.
Yeah.
Nothing wrong.
It's all good.
It's only when you tell other men that
you have to conform to this.
I think that's where the problem is.
I think people should be allowed to be
into what they're into.
Yes,
and the idea that you're transphobic,
and I've seen this,
I've seen articles written where they're
shitting on men that are not willing to
date women with penises.
They call it the.
No,
sorry,
the cotton.
The cotton ceiling is the other way
around.
When it's a male to female person and
women don't want to date them.
Lesbians
don't want to date them because they
have a penis.
What do they call it?
The cotton ceiling because it's like the
glass ceiling.
Acceptance has to do with underwear.
She's Christ.
So lesbians who don't want to date trans
women because penises.
Yeah.
What a wonderful world we live in.
I like it.
I liked it.
This world is weird.
I do.
So this is where
I think I get why people would see what
I've said and think that it's
transphobic.
I get like who I am.
I get that,
that it's a problem.
I get just looking at me as a problem.
I mean I'm,
I'm,
I'm a cage fighting commentator,
you know,
I'm a dirty standup comedian.
This,
I mean,
I've seen like I would be your enemy,
but people shouldn't assume,
right?
Like you're your own person so you might
look a certain way.
It's just what people do.
It's the same way a guy looks at a chick
with a Dick and goes,
yikes,
what do we got going on here?
Let me just.
I just think as me,
as an individual,
as a human being,
one thing I like about it is I like
things that are weird.
I like things that defy the standard
definition.
I'm the same.
Think it's more interesting.
It's far more interesting.
Yeah.
It's interesting when you talked to
neuroscientists,
whereas a playboy tee shirt,
right?
You're a Weirdo.
Yeah.
Do you like it?
Yeah,
it's cool.
It's a cool,
clever.
You are a Weirdo.
I am aware though for sure.
And that relates to your sense of humor
too though,
because my sense of humor is really dry
and I feel that's part of the way I look
at the world and why I appreciate the
world the way.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
for sure.
I embrace the weird.
Yes,
I really do.
I'd love it.
I'd love that.
Things are strange.
I do.
I think it's interesting.
I really do.
I think so.
I think everything's interesting.
I mean,
I,
and I try to cultivate that.
I really do.
I go out of my way to try to look at
things with fresh eyes and especially
because I smoke a lot of pot and so
whenever I do that I kind of always have
a new way of looking at it.
Like,
oh,
I never even thought about it that way,
but that's one of the things that are
really like about marijuana.
And I tried.
I've tried to explain that to people
that don't smoke pot.
I got a conversation with Ted nugent
about that and one of the things,
because he had this perception that
people smoke pot or lazy and Ne'er do
wells.
I'm like,
dude,
I can't have enough jobs.
I have so many.
I do do so many fucking super high
functioning.
I'm always doing something.
I'm not lazy,
but I get the benefit that I get out of
it as a benefit.
That is not often.
It's not,
uh,
it's not often promoted.
And that benefit is there's something
good about being nervous,
there's something good about what people
call paranoia is something good about
heightened perspective that is brought
upon by psychedelics or buy marijuana
where you are forced to reexamine what
you've taken for granted.
And that's what I like about it.
And so what I like about one of the
things that I like about smoking pot,
besides the fact that I believe it makes
me more compassionate,
it makes it instills a better sense of
community.
It makes me more friendly and more
loving and it definitely does that,
but it also makes me look at things with
fresh eyes and appreciate the weirdness,
the weird.
Like I genuinely love it when I see like
some girl.
Do you know Bailey?
Jay is a trans woman with a giant Dick.
She got pictures of her Dick.
Is Jamie going to pull it up right now
and think you can.
We'll get kicked off of youtube.
But I love it.
I like the fact that it's real.
It doesn't bother me.
Happy.
I think it's fun.
Are you going to enjoy a more fulfilled?
No,
no I'm not.
But I,
I like the fact that they exist,
I do acceptance and I like the fact that
people liked them and I liked the fact
that it makes certain people happy if it
makes them happy or people that are
attracted to them happy.
I really do like it.
I don't,
uh,
don't like definitions I don't like.
I don't like restrictions,
you know,
so where people would get an incorrect
assumption is my radical stance against
this trans woman fighting other women
because I recognize that as being unfair
and not well because there's suppression
of the debate as well.
Yeah.
It's one thing if you could talk about
it openly.
Well,
it's also something that I'm an expert
in,
so I'm like,
stop,
don't,
don't try to compare this to fucking
tennis because even in tennis it wasn't
fair,
but this is a different thing.
It just,
it's a radically different thing.
It's interesting because I heard you
talk about this,
I don't know if it was your interview
with Josh Barnett,
but when you first get into the cage,
you don't know what the other person is
going to be like until you start
fighting.
Just imagine,
you know,
if you go in and you don't know that
someone was born male,
how that's very big disadvantage.
I think there's a propensity for
violence that exists in the mind of a
man that I just don't know if it's the
same in most women.
I just think,
I don't know how much of that.
Like I don't know if you turn me into a
woman,
how much of that you would squeeze out?
I don't know,
but I know there's a switch that men
have because I've seen it go off.
I've seen,
I've probably seen more people get
fucked up in real life than 99 point
nine percent of people that have ever
lived other than like,
you know,
people lived in Roman times and we get
chopped up by swords,
but people in modern time,
I can targe fisticuffs people getting
head kicked and beaten down with elbows.
I've probably seen more of that than
almost anyone that's ever lived is sort
of probably a small group of people.
I got thousand people on the planet that
seen as many people get fucked up
personally is I have,
so I did you.
Did you date at chunk you?
You get a sense of what you're seeing.
You get a sense of and you,
you understand there's a,
there's a,
there's,
there's a technical violence that women
are capable of.
For sure.
I mean especially like extreme examples
like cris cyborg is like super violent
or when Holly Holm head kicked Ronda
Rousey and then hammer fists at her
while she was unconscious.
Super violent,
but also very technical violence.
And then there's an extreme over the top
masculine violence that I've seen that's
even more ferocious.
There's,
there's something to it that is another
level this in.
And this is not saying that men are
better than women.
This is not.
This is just I'm saying there's a thing
that men do.
There's a reason why men cause all wars.
Men Cause all wars.
Women are fucking suit up and going into
battle and,
and,
and trying to conquer as a giant,
you know,
million strong group of women,
soldiers invading a foreign army.
No,
this is not happening.
This is a male behavior.
Testosterone.
It is.
And it,
it's also.
There's something about males.
This,
this switch,
this violent switch that exists.
It exists in a very dark way.
Women are capable of shooting people,
stabbing people and doing all these
things.
Don't get me wrong,
I'm not saying that,
but it does not happen in the same
numbers that it happens with men.
It just doesn't.
And I think that this is something that
also has to be taken into consideration
when you talk to you about men versus
women.
Like it's a,
it's a different thing and people don't
think it's a different thing have
probably never been punched in the face
by a guy you know,
or seeing guys punch guys in the face or
been around it enough where you realize
like it's a different thing.
You know,
I've seen some awesome women fights,
awesome women fights amazing,
super technical,
even very violent,
but God damn it,
there's a different.
There's a difference.
It's just not the same thing.
Yeah,
no,
I would definitely agree with that and
most people would.
But if in today's climate,
in certain circles that would be
considered transphobic or maybe even
sexist,
well,
there's also this narrative that women,
because they need to be like men and
some level women have to be as strong as
men and I've seen this where they will
put like published piece of saying women
are as strong as men physically strong
and that's not even true.
It's not true.
Only there's a not true.
It's you can demonstrate it like
scientifically it's not true.
You look at the data in terms of what
men have,
what,
what they can do.
Like this is this guy,
this woman who used to be a man who is
now competing in weightlifting and
Australia,
like everybody's going crazy over this
one who is fucking crazy.
It doesn't make any sense that they're
allowing this.
If this is so nonsensical,
if you want to have trans transgender
Olympics,
go for it.
Do that,
but to try to pretend until we come up
with some sort of a way like with crispr
or whatever we talked about before,
where you can actually turn a man into a
woman,
turn a woman into a man until it's real
clean.
We look at it and go,
Yup,
we just did the chromosome test.
You've got a y chromosome now and you've
erased 30 years of testosterone and you
know a man now is built like you.
Right?
Then we're good.
We're good now.
It's an actual woman.
Yeah.
Until then,
man,
you're dealing with some hardcore
variables and to not to be in denial of
those variables is silly and I'm gonna
I'm going to stand against it every time
because I think it's.
I see what it is.
I mean,
this is like a religious ideology,
you're,
you're purposely ignoring facts.
Do you feel like most people in the
industry.
I agree with you or how did they feel
it?
Yeah.
Oh fuck.
Oh yeah.
The people who don't is a minor group
and they're all like super progressive,
left wing,
left leaning and some of them were
scared to talk about it because other
people aren't as vocal.
Well,
they just didn't want to get the
blowback.
It's all it is.
But in terms of like fighters,
it was like a hundred percent mean
Ashley.
Evan Smith is a fucking beast for taking
that fight and even tougher for winning.
But then again,
she went into the UFC.
She,
she's in a UFC level fighter,
which is,
there's a big difference,
you know,
and what she was kicking me.
If you look at like the caliber of
competition that she's fought,
guys like Raquel Pennington or girls,
excuse me,
like Raquel Pennington,
sorry,
Raquel.
And look at who found foxes fighting
when she was fighting,
you know,
lower level competitions.
That's a giant leap between Raquel
Pennington and someone who is on these
amateur circuits and Raquel Pennington
beat Ashley Evan Smith.
Crazy fight was submitted with a bulldog
choke with like one second ago.
We're screaming.
It was nuts.
Covered in blood.
It's fucking chaos.
Right?
But this is like super elite world
championship level fighting.
That's the difference,
right?
Yeah.
It's just fucking different,
you know?
Yeah.
So there was a lot of people that
supported me,
but I knew I was right.
You know,
I was like,
no,
that other people are secretly agreeing
with you.
I will not even secretly,
they just didn't want to talk about it
publicly.
It wasn't that.
It was a secret,
you know,
there was no people that were coming up
to me disagreeing with me.
Trans people were agreeing with me,
trans people that I'm friends with,
like,
that shit is crazy.
That bitch is out of her fucking mind.
It was funny and also in the long run
over many,
many conversations about it,
people realize,
okay,
I see your perspective.
Like you're not discriminatory.
No,
it's just about combat sports and even
about weightlifting,
it's like,
come on man,
imagine if you a woman and all your
life,
you've been fucking power cleaning
through the force of will and
determination and your focus and
discipline,
and then some trans woman comes in and
just his bitches lifting 100 pounds more
than you're ever going to live and
you're like,
well,
what the fuck?
This isn't fair that those poor girls in
Texas that had a wrestle that girl
because they're discriminatory in the
opposite way and they won't recognize
that this trans girls,
a boy or this trans boy is a boy get
injured too.
Fuck yeah,
yeah,
mean literally you're allowing someone.
You're allowing girls to take steroids.
That's what you're doing.
You're saying one girl can take steroids
because she thinks she's a boy.
We don't think she's a boy,
so we'll let her take steroids.
It's like,
why are you letting her take steroids?
This?
Why are you late or take testosterone?
Do you know how old that girl was or
that we've seven chance,
boy,
okay,
one states two years in a row.
Wow.
Shocker.
But you know,
by taking those,
by taking testosterone too,
he is sterilizing himself.
Yeah.
Which is crazy at that age.
I want to say specifically of that
person,
but just in general.
Well,
as a neuroscientist in your
understanding of the frontal lobe and
the development of human,
because you realize like your decision
making capabilities not fully formed,
not till you're almost 30.
So I just want people should vote.
That's when they,
that's when they should make any sort of
important decision.
But it's crazy because you think a 17
year old or even like A.
I don't even 21 year old can decide if
they want to be sterile for life.
No,
no.
If you gave me a chance at 17 to get a
vasectomy,
I might've done it.
You know,
now I'm happy I have kids,
but it's um,
it's an irreversible decision,
which is why it gets weird.
Right.
It's like if you decide to sterilize
yourself at testosterone,
is there any.
Coming back from that,
have you started taking estrogen again?
Where your,
where your cycle kicked back in?
No.
Well,
once you start taking cross sex
hormones.
No,
no,
and it's amazing because parents are
saying,
well,
you know,
if that's the decision they want to
make,
then they should make that decision and
they're okay with it.
What's interesting too is the language
that we use and that people use in the
media now.
If there was a story about a woman who
just gave birth.
Oh,
tell me more actually,
because I thought I thought I was
thinking of something,
but I think it's something else.
She used to be a woman.
She'd be,
she was transitioning to being a man and
she got pregnant.
Okay.
But became a full man.
Oh,
after she gave birth,
had her breast removed the deal.
Right.
Celebrated,
celebrated as this men give birth.
But it was,
well,
not only that,
she,
I don't think she breastfed was,
shouldn't be celebrated.
Like,
like there's massive amounts of evidence
that breastfeeding is super positive
because that look at that full beard
holding a baby.
So clearly taking the testosterone
again,
if not taking it while the baby's in the
womb.
And uh,
I'm sure five years after having a child
as a woman,
what transgender man gives birth to baby
five years after having a child as a
woman.
Okay.
So she had a child as a woman and then
she got pregnant again as a man.
That's what they're saying.
Okay.
What does that mean?
What's going on there?
Magic.
You are an alien.
So I guess it isn't impossible to get
pregnant.
But if you're straight from pubertal
blockers,
straight onto cross sex hormones,
you know,
your body hasn't even really developed.
So in that case,
so as a grown up,
it's less likely that you will become
sterile.
Is that the case?
I think it depends on how.
I'm not an endocrinologist,
but I think it has to do with how long
you've been on the hormones and probably
how old you were when you started.
Right?
But in this case,
I mean I've,
I've seen cases too where trans women
will breastfeed but there and the
doctors say this is an amazing thing,
but they're taking hormone.
So basically those hormones are going to
the baby when they're
breastfeeding the boy.
I feel,
I mean I even feel bad saying child in
danger mode.
I know I feel bad saying this right now,
but why I feel it feels like I'm placing
judgment I guess
shouldn't be placing judgment.
While we were talking about something
that's publicly projected,
something that's in the news,
they chose to make this.
They chose to be there with their
cameras were taking pictures of them.
They're proclaiming this,
that the other side isn't being
presented to.
I think that's part of the problem is
the other side of the things that we're
saying.
Yes.
Well this is what.
So what are the other thoughts?
What is the other side?
Well,
the one side of being that is
progressive and if you identify as a
woman and you have a child,
then you should raise that child as if
that's no different from any other
woman,
but she doesn't identify as a woman.
She identifies as a man or not this
person,
the person I was talking about who is
breastfeeding
male-to-female,
you can breastfeed male to female.
Oh,
oh,
wait a minute for that.
It's not his kid,
her kid.
Oh boy,
we worth this is why those gender
pronouns,
Jordan Peterson was wrong.
This is why we need all these separate
gender pronouns.
All 72 of them.
Well,
here's the other thing,
this male transgender male obviously
still likes dudes.
The one we just saw because she got
pregnant by a guy.
Yep.
So stay at check,
Bro.
I don't know as just telling you to do
whatever you want to do,
but you know,
we should probably take into
consideration the idea that maybe this
isn't the best thing for that child to
be subjected to hormones.
No,
that's,
that's the bottom line.
I think whether a parent is trans or not
have a bearing on their ability to
parent.
So while that trans man was pregnant,
did he continue his testosterone
therapy?
Is the question,
right?
That's the question.
Hold this one says no.
That's how will they get pregnant?
Oh,
so they backed off to have a baby on
purpose.
They were,
they took,
they got off the testosterone for health
reasons and then got pregnant.
That's this particular case.
Health reasons.
Yeah.
But I thought it was natural and
awesome.
It's good for you.
That's the other thing too,
right?
If it is natural,
why do you have to have synthetic
hormones injected into your body that
are not endogenous like they did not
even supposed to be in your body?
This is so crazy.
We live in such a bizarro world.
Seeing a guy with a beard who was fully
pregnant with a hairy chest is so
fucking odd.
I'd assume me as a hairy chest.
It's also,
I mean,
it goes against people who say that
gender is a social construct.
Why do you need to take testosterone
then to meet the opposite sex?
Well,
this is one of the weirdest things that
the argument that I had,
um,
about one person online where they said
about Fallon Fox,
they said she's always been a woman.
And I said even when she was having sex
with a woman and got her pregnant and
she said yes.
Even then I'm like,
we're done.
We're done here.
We were in make believe land now.
But what does that mean?
Your role?
You were a woman when you were having
sex with a woman.
So why not just stay that woman who has
sex with women?
I think it's because people want to have
sympathy.
Right?
And so it's kind of like,
that's a nice story to tell.
Yes,
but it's not,
it's not true,
but that's the problem is that you're
not dealing with reality.
You're,
you're,
you're into this weird fantasy land that
opens you up to massive amounts of
criticism from people that might be
discriminatory instead of saying,
yeah,
this is problematic and weird and
strange,
and the whole thing is weird.
Instead of saying that saying,
no,
she's always been a woman.
Well the fuck does that mean it's such a
blanket statement to write,
but it's a wonderful thing to do to shut
down all rational critique of this
situation.
It's a wonderful way to do it.
She's always been a woman.
Like,
really?
That's the only way they can win too
though.
Because if you actually enter into a
conversation,
you have to actually think about your
position right now.
Actually think of ways to argue with the
other person.
And that takes effort.
Yes.
So it's a lot easier just to simply say
they were wrong and you can't argue with
someone's lived experience.
It doesn't just take effort.
It's
also an acknowledgement of the oddity of
the situation.
Like there's you have to take into
account,
like if you're,
if you're not committed to one side or
the and you're looking at it for what it
really is,
you really have to go,
wow.
It's so strange.
Like be open minded,
be accepting,
be completely embracing of all oddities,
strange,
different variables of the,
the,
the broad spectrum of human sexuality.
Be Open to all of it,
but also be aware of how fucking weird
it is because it is weird.
It's not.
You don't have to have hate in your
heart to recognize that.
It's strange to see a guy with a beard
breastfeeding,
right?
Yeah.
You know,
or fully pregnant.
It's fucking strange.
I mean it just is.
Then I think if you're a curious person
too,
you know,
you want to learn more and you want to
ask questions,
but like in the climate now you can't
even do that even if your heart isn't a
good place.
Yeah.
But it's hard for people to know that
your heart is in a good place.
It's just part of the problem when you
know you don't fall in line with the
accepted narrative.
People think,
well,
oh,
it must be because you're conservative
or you're transphobic or homophobic or
something wrong where you're not on
board with the way people are thinking
today.
You're stuck in the past and that it's
on the wrong side of history.
That's a good one.
But it's just,
you know,
it's hard to fully express your feelings
on nuanced tissues.
Yeah.
Well,
it takes effort,
right?
It takes time and you have to actually
think about what is your position and
you actually have to look at the facts
and then have a nuance position.
Because I don't think most of these
issues,
you can't just simply go with one side
or the other across the board or simply
go with what sounds nice.
There's usually a lot of other stuff
underlying that that needs to kind of be
hashed out.
What is your transition into academia
from academia to the,
you know,
doing what you do now.
Being able to write things and do
podcasts and be free of that sort of
create what has that been like,
the process or what?
What led me to do it
both the process.
What law you will,
you were described what led you to do
it?
Okay.
So I just finished my phd last year and
the last two years I realized that
academia changed a lot.
So when I first two years and I would
say in the four years I did my phd,
it changed a lot.
So when I started there are certain
topics that were in little taboo but you
could still ask questions and I had
planned to stay in academia and continue
being a sex researcher.
I love sex research,
but I realized as time went on that you
can ask important questions anymore and
especially when it comes to gender,
sex differences and gender dysphoria.
So at the time,
um,
with regards to the debate on kids with
gender dysphoria there,
every single mainstream news piece in
left leaning outlets was saying young
kids should transition.
That's the best thing for them.
And so you'd see all this coverage of
young kids who had transitioned to the
opposite sex and their parents were
elated,
the kids were doing so well.
Uh,
but from a scientific perspective,
that's not what the research shows.
As I said,
most kids will grow their feelings,
so it's best to just wait and see.
And so I wrote an op ed about that and
at the time I wrote it and I sat on it
for probably about six months trying to
decide whether I should really try and
get it published because I knew that
people were gonna be really upset even
though I was just talking about the
scientific literature.
And I asked my colleagues,
what do you think?
And they said to me,
I said,
should I wait until I have tenure to
publish this?
And they said,
even if you have tenure,
it's not going to protect you nowadays.
So,
uh,
you know,
I was lucky.
My mentors have always been very
supportive of looking at facts and
looking at the truth and don't worry
about whether it's politically incorrect
or not.
Just say you do a study,
just present what you found,
don't worry about how people are going
to take it,
but not everyone is like that and
especially even in the hard sciences now
if you publish the,
I mean it won't even get published now
if you find things that are
controversial because journals don't
want to have to deal with that.
The institutions don't want have to deal
with that,
so I made the decision to publish that
op Ed and then from there I said,
well,
I'm going to see what this journalism
thing can take me,
and so now I say whatever I want.
Well that sort of behavior and that
thought process is such on their side is
such a weakening or the foundation of
critical thinking and the.
It also comes at the same time as these
platforms like podcasting and youtube
that allows a person like you or like
Jordan Peterson to now disconnect and
have a far larger audience.
Although it is scary.
There was quite a bit of censorship
going on with some of those platforms.
With Youtube.
Yeah.
Youtube blogs to they they.
They have the cute thing they do.
They demonetize things.
I'd probably do you monetize this
podcast?
For sure.
They even let you upload it after.
Although let us upload.
Okay.
But the demonetization,
especially since we're criticized
youtube,
as soon as you criticize you,
that's like one of the best ways to get
demonetized from one of their videos is
to criticize them.
Yeah,
it's fucking squirrely.
It's also make people like if you're
subscribed,
they don't tell people when videos get
posted,
something like that.
Right.
They do some weird shit.
I don't pay attention,
just upload it and keep moving,
but I have friends who were there.
It's their main source of income was
youtube and videos and advertising for
them was a disaster.
Like people that were making a lot of
money and then all sudden that money was
cut down to 30 percent of what it used
to be and with no,
no clear guidelines.
The problem with the guidelines is even
if like say if we have a video and they
just decide that they don't like the
video,
you can't really protest it.
You can protest it and.
But then they review it and then they
uphold their initial ruling and they
don't tell you why.
There's no.
They don't say,
well,
hey,
you called someone a queer or you did
this or no,
no.
They just say,
yeah,
this is how it is.
And it's subjective.
Yeah,
well it's a problem with being a
monopoly and they're not a monopoly in
the fact that there's not other video
platforms,
but there are certainly the largest by
far in terms of like user uploaded video
platforms.
There's not even a close second,
which is kinda weird.
It's amazing that they've done it,
you know,
I mean,
there's nothing remotely like it.
I know a bunch of people thought about
building one and I've been contacted by
people that are starting up a new one.
They want me to join that and like,
good luck,
good luck.
I mean,
youtube is so far ahead.
It's like,
how do you catch up to them?
And I don't think they're evil by any
stretch of the imagination.
And uh,
I had a conversation with someone about
it pretty recently where she was
describing that they're really,
they're,
they're using crude tools and this is
part of the problem with what,
what is being deemed as censorship is
really they're trying to root out hate
speech and they're doing so with crude
tools that will eventually through ai
get better and better.
Is that it though,
or is it that they're trying to shut
down any sort of dissenting points of
view?
I don't know.
You know,
I think they definitely lean hard left.
They definitely do.
So does google.
They lean hard left.
That was proven by the paper and the,
you know,
how it was received,
the memo
actually,
you know what,
because I was doing youtube for a bit
and then I stopped just because I
unfortunately didn't have time because
my writing is like my number one thing.
But I had one video that minute it went
up.
I was talking about science on gender
dysphoria.
Got Demonetized literally like 20
minutes.
And I thought,
Oh,
you know,
I know what my intentions are.
And it's really unsettling when that
happens.
It will,
it should be because you're not doing
anything hateful know,
and what they're doing is they're trying
to make subjects much less attractive to
discuss [inaudible] and who's doing it.
I mean is it doing it through crude
tools or someone looking at it and
flagging it and deciding that this is
not something they want to be involved
with advertising and in their defense,
a lot of this got started off by people
that were really doing fucked up things
on youtube and they had to respond and
they had to figure out a way to
eliminate that stuff in their platform
and I think once you start censoring,
the tendency is to continue to expand.
This tendency is not to back off of that
center ship.
Like you know,
we're just gonna allow Holocaust deniers
and racists and make your videos.
His Youtube is a wild west baby aren't
going to do that because they have
advertisers and there's a significant
amount of revenue that they get from
that,
but they don't actually end the
conversation though.
People just get upset and they take the
car.
They might not be on youtube,
but that people are still talking about
these things,
but they're not youtube
as long as they're not on youtube,
they don't give a shit like,
yeah,
you're not on youtube.
Good luck with that conversation on
Vimeo or wherever you're going to go.
It's,
um,
it's,
it's odd.
But it's also,
I've,
I love it.
I love that there's these disco.
I love the law part of me even likes the
fact that things are being censored.
I really do.
I find it fascinating.
I feel like the argument is fascinating
because I think first of all,
I think censorship clearly causes that.
I think when you push against something,
there's a natural reaction.
That reaction is to bolster your
defenses and fire back up.
And,
uh,
I think there's certainly some of that
going on.
You can't really quiet ideas entirely,
but you do,
you do expose your intentions and you
expose these blind spots that are what
we've been discussing all day.
There's this political ideology,
a blind spots that people have these
ideological holes that they have and the
way they look at things.
Question is,
do you want to solve the problem or are
you trying to just be successful as a
business if you want to solve the
problem?
I don't think suppressing speech and
shutting down people who are genuinely
just trying to ask questions and have
conversations.
I don't think that's going to solve
things.
I don't think they're trying to solve
any problems.
I think they're trying to make a ton of
money and they're also very liberal and
they think the right thing to do is to
suppress certain ideology.
They deemed harmful or hate speech.
You know,
I had a conversation with a woman as a
youtube exec.
She was telling me that Douglas Murray
and Sam Harris,
they there this podcast that they did
online and uh,
some guy put it up in his playlist and
he got a community guideline strike for
having it in this playlist.
And I said,
how is that?
And she said,
it's hate speech.
I said,
it's his speech speech.
I heard that podcast.
And not only is it not hate speech,
you didn't watch it.
She didn't listen to it like she had no
idea what the fuck it was,
but she just like confidently said it to
me like I was going to just shut up.
Like you're out of your fucking mind.
You don't even know what you're talking
about.
This is hilarious,
but it was a person out of pretty high
level over there.
So it's interesting to see that like,
okay,
well this is the kind of a lack of
critical thinking that we're discussing.
This is the kind of blind spot that
we're discussing that you feel like you
could just say that instead of
appreciate that this is to intellectuals
discussing something that's very complex
and that is,
it was about immigration and about Islam
and those are two things that people
don't want to hear.
You know,
they just like go.
Those two things are off limits.
Unless you're a pro Islam or pro
immigration,
you better shut the fuck up or we're
going to demonetize you and that,
that kind of censorship is fascinating
to me because it's not effective.
It's,
it just,
it just makes people go,
hey,
and you know,
and then it,
it makes the people on the youtube side
get defensive and it makes them double
down and you know,
and you're seeing,
you see that now.
I mean,
you see it with many people.
It's,
it's a weird time for ideas.
Yeah.
How do you feel about being part of the
Idw,
the international dark web?
Um,
I'm the least mentioned,
happily the least mentioned person in
that group.
I'm very happy about that.
I don't like being in any groups.
Would a,
Groucho Marx once a,
uh,
I don't want to be a part of any club
that would have me look.
I'm very happy to be able to have a
platform where I can have people like
you on or any of those people,
whether it's Bret Weinstein or Eric
Weinstein Stein,
sorry guys.
Bret Weinstein era after harvey.
Everybody got real.
He's really sweet.
He's great.
And his wife Heather is amazing as well.
He'll be on actually the next season of
wrong speak.
Oh cool.
Heather hiding his wife is amazing too.
And they were on together and Sam Harris
is a good friend and I love that guy.
He's a fascinating person.
And as,
as Jordan and a look,
I don't agree with a lot of what Ben
Shapiro says.
He's a super nice guy and I really like
them,
you know?
And that's,
that's.
You saw that thing that happened with
that actor.
Mark was the same mark duplass.
Is that a same,
got in trouble for tweeting that?
A very nice and reasonable person.
Yeah.
It's a fun time.
Ben Is really nice too.
He's a really nice guy,
you know,
I liked them a lot.
This internet,
whatever it is,
the dark web thing,
that's all eric.
Eric Weinstein's idea was to name this
and label.
He loves all that Shit.
He loves all that cloak and dagger
stuff.
He gets kicked out of it,
but he makes some very good points and
he's a brilliant,
brilliant guy.
And um,
this idea that we're all joined
together.
I mean we all went,
uh,
we had a big dinner together,
like a bunch of dorks and we all got
together and were like this little club.
And that's kind of fun and we're going
to do it again and we're bringing more
people into bringing more people into
the dark web.
Some people are resentful that they're
not a part of the dark web and I'll tell
you some names afterwards,
but some people like contacted Barry
Weiss and were upset that they weren't
included in the dark web.
I loved berries column.
It was interesting.
It's the whole but the label of it all.
I mean it's.
What's interesting is it,
it starts this conversation,
right?
So why is it even necessary to have this
dark web and what's the function of this
dark web?
What is this?
What is the dark web doing really like
what is,
you know,
and there was an article today where
someone was calling it problematic and
saying that it's mostly right people,
which is
absolutely not true.
Sam Harris very left Bret Weinstein,
fiercely progressive.
Eric very left.
I'm way more left than I am,
right to the very few right wing ideas
that I hold onto the very small.
It was very.
The vast majority of my positions on
things side with,
with people on the left,
vast majority,
I'm Ben Shapiro,
was very right,
but he's reasonable,
you know,
and he's also a young guy,
conservative religious.
It's,
but he's also extremely intelligent and
reasonable.
Talked to him and he has himself
disavowed some of the things that he
said and he's,
he's himself criticized his own words.
He wrote a whole column.
Here's a list of all the stupid things
I've ever said online because he's,
he's,
you know,
he's a very aware guy,
very self aware.
I think,
um,
I think it's important to have
discussions and I think it's important
that when people feel like those
discussions are being suppressed,
that they talk about that.
And I think that's what this whole thing
is.
And I think you're a part of that as
well.
I was in the column.
Yeah,
we could use you in the dark web,
a woman of color that you guys aren't
all racist much white people.
God Damn it.
I took a 23 and me and I'm hoping I've
got some black and Korean.
I'm hoping for you to give me some.
Give me more than five percent.
What is it that you have to have?
I think you only have to have like one
slash 16th native American to catch a
check and some places.
I'm not sure what it is in Canada,
but something like that.
Yeah.
Like if you go fishing in,
in Canada and you're a first nation,
if you have an a what the number is,
but you could bring as many fish as you
want,
but like if you like I was fishing in
Canada in a place where I could only get
one Walleye a day.
You only get one,
but there was some dude next to me was
first nations.
Homeboy was just pulling them in.
Dr Wright and sticking them in a bucket.
Clean it up.
So you better be hoping on that test
then.
I'm hoping.
I'm hoping I'm praying.
I just want to be discriminated against.
One 16th is one great great
grandparents.
Oh,
that's all you need.
That's all I need.
Somebody come on chimp in your family
too.
For sure.
Somebody fucked a champ.
This is what I think.
I think if people evolved from lower
hominids,
right,
that's what happened.
That if you believe all that evolution
nonsense,
no one believes that anymore.
It's pseudoscience.
Yeah.
It's a bunch of pseudo science,
but I think that somewhere in my
ancestry,
somebody went back in for one more shot
chimp when they probably shouldn't have
somebody said I was going to know.
They probably got drunk.
No judgment,
no judgment.
And clearly evolution is not.
It's not a fucking straight flat plane.
Right.
It varies.
Yeah.
You can't deny the influence of it,
you know,
that's some people do.
Yeah.
Well,
I dunno.
What do you think about all this dark
web stuff?
Um,
I,
I felt,
I mean,
the fact that the New York Times covered
it give me a sense of relief because
sometimes the things I write,
I don't feel like the things I write are
that controversial or that offensive.
But the response I get sometimes,
I'm surprised
you said this as,
as a journalist,
as intellectual,
as a person who actually understands
what you're talking.
Yeah.
Especially someone who has studied,
especially these certain topics within
research,
I think I know what I'm talking about,
and so when people get really mad it
makes you question where are we going?
So the fact that,
you know,
Barry covered this and I'm that the
response was so positive.
I mean,
people got mad too.
Oh,
people got mad at her.
She's taken a lot of heat.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely a lot.
Yeah.
But I feel a little bit more optimistic
because it,
it tells me that people get it,
that we have conversations like this and
people don't think that we're bigoted or
that were coming from.
We have a nefarious agenda,
right?
We just want to have conversations and
talk about things that aren't being
discussed in the mainstream.
Yeah.
That's where censorship becomes very
dangerous if you do silence a lot of
these conversations and right now
they're not being silenced even though
they're,
they're being democratized to a certain
extent.
That is a problem,
but the conversation still exists and as
long as they do still existent,
the vast majority exist in audio form
anyway.
And podcasting is the vast majority of
the volume of people that are
downloading these kinds of
conversations.
I think it's an incredibly unique time
for the distribution of ideas.
I don't think there's ever any ever been
anything remotely like this in human
history.
There's never been a time where someone
like me can just do something,
uh,
just on a laptop with a Webcam and then
nine years later it's this,
you know,
we're just fucking nuts and I don't
even.
I'm aware of it,
but I don't even think about it that
much honestly.
I just do it.
I'm,
I was excited to talk to you today.
I was looking forward to it.
I was excited to too.
But I don't,
I don't give it much consideration as
far as the impact because I think as
soon as you do that,
it'll slip through your fingers.
Like if you think too much about it.
Yeah.
Well,
I definitely wouldn't say half the Shit
I've already said today.
Right.
That's,
that's appeal
though.
The appeal is that you and I,
I really believe this.
If there was no microphone,
we probably would never have this
conversation because it's too difficult
to sit.
It would be too weird like you and I was
just going to sit down and just talk to
each other.
Was came in and met you and we sat down.
Would be weird,
like you almost have to have this where
people could see it to do it because
otherwise you'd check your phone.
I check my phone,
get up,
go to the bathroom.
It's like it would be a normal thing to
do,
but by putting these headphones on and
by having this microphone in front of
our face,
we lock in and know that how many
million people are going to be watching
fuck load.
It's more every week.
It's growing in a weird way like a
fucking mold.
It's amazing.
Strange,
but this is the only way we would have
this conversation and it's made me far
better at talking to people and
understanding conversations and
understanding what they are and also
examining my own speech patterns and the
way I communicate and getting better at
it.
I like how you said you started it just
because you wanted to talk to people.
Like I think that's what it should be.
It should just be that interest in
having a conversation.
Well,
I used to like doing radio when I was a
guest,
you know,
uncertain radio shows,
like you do.
Like if I was going to go to phoenix or
something like that,
I would go do stand up there.
I would have to promote it on the radio
and the old days and I would get there
and I would get there early and you
know,
smoke a joint beforehand,
drink a cup of coffee and get in and
start talking shit and having a good
time and laughing and be like,
oh,
that'd be fun to have a radio show man,
you know,
just go in there and just talk and have
fun.
But the problem was to me it was like
always the censorship.
I was like,
Oh,
you got to censor yourself.
Then I started doing the open anthony
show and opie and anthony had a show on,
you know as first if it was Xm,
then it became serious and and then they
split up,
but when I would do that it was opie and
Anthony and Jim Norton and I was like,
this is the best,
this is so fun and the way they did it,
credit to them,
the way they did it was different than
any radio show at ever been a part of
because it was no structure at all.
They would just bring comics in.
It would just be me and Ari should fear
and bill burr and Joey Diaz and all
these guys.
They would just come in and hang out and
talk shit.
There was no structure at all.
It was just.
Anthony is such a smart and funny guide.
Opie would sort of run the thing and and
Jim was there and they would just let
everybody talk and I'd be like,
this would be amazing.
You could just come in and hang out and
have fun and then I'm done.
I started doing a podcast after that,
but it was because of that and then
anthony did a thing called live from the
compound.
He calls his house the compound and he
did like this thing in his basement.
We had a green screen and he did his own
show and he did Karaoke while he's
holding a machine gun.
He's fucking crazy.
Anthony is like a legit gun nut,
but he had a studio that he built in his
basement with like legitimate equipment
and I went,
oh,
and that inspired me and that,
that is literally what started me off to
do a podcast.
The scene that he had set this up in his
basement and I was like,
don't just fucking just start doing it.
Yeah.
Wow.
I was going to say the same thing.
I feel the wrong speed.
The fact that I can see people being
mommed and I can think,
okay,
I wonder what they're like and I can
just ask them like,
is that what it's like for you?
You see someone you think,
I just want to talk to them?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Especially someone in a controversial
position like Jordan,
like when I first met Jordan,
it's like when he was just starting to
get some attention online and I wanted
to talk to them,
I was like,
well,
what is going on here and why?
Why is everybody be up so upset at you?
And I've never met anyone in in all my
life who is so purposely misrepresented
by other people than Jordan.
Yeah,
I've never seen it before.
It's,
it's amazing to see intelligent,
articulate people clearly lying about
his positions,
about how and not and not even
understanding that by doing that they're
strengthening him and they're
strengthening their.
You're not going to lie to the point
where people are going to really
think that your position is correct and
all these things that Jordan has said
that somehow or another you misheard
them or the whole world ms dot heard
them.
Oh,
you're misrepresenting his positions and
that just makes all the people that are
siding with him realize he's right.
Yeah.
It strengthened Sam.
They literally don't understand that
they are his publicists.
They are helping.
They are proving his point and to the
point where he's selling out.
He sold out gigantic 5,000
seat theaters.
Yeah.
He's selling them out all over the world
just talking.
It's crazy.
He's making millions of dollars because
of them being stupid.
It's fucking amazing.
It's really amazing and all of it came
out of him putting his foot down in
opposition to the very same things that
you experienced that forced you to leave
academia is misrepresenting of reality.
That seems to be going in and I think
it's fueling the.
It's certainly fueling the dark web,
but on top of that,
these people are seeing that they can't
trust what they're being told.
Yeah,
they are.
They can't trust what they're being told
and they.
They understand that there's other
conversation to be had out there.
There was an article that I tweeted
today that was really interesting.
I was like,
wow,
this is crazy.
It was talking about long form podcasts
and the ability that longform podcast
have to allow people to have rational
civil discourse instead of just like
getting on these fucking CNN shows and
yelling at each other for three minutes,
which is sometimes you get a panel.
Everyone just agrees with each other.
Yes.
Yeah.
Or the panels are crazy too.
How the fuck you going to have nine
people talking at the same time that
it's crazy.
It's hard to do.
When I do podcasts with two other
people,
it's hard.
Well,
it's entertainment,
but it's not a good way to discuss
topics,
you know,
long form conversations are really the
only way where you can get a good sense
of where someone stands on a position
and how they think,
you know,
like I get a chance to see like you like
and a lot of people are going to get a
chance to see you today.
How you think about things,
what,
what your thought process is,
and if there's holes in that thought
process,
they get exposed.
And that's I think also with issues that
are more complex.
You can talk about all the different
nuances to that issue because if you
just simply have your talking points and
you sort of.
If you do like a standard interview
that's say seven minutes long,
it's going to be very,
very sparse in terms of what you're
saying.
Yeah.
I mean there's not a single thing we
discussed today that wasn't 15 minutes
long at least.
Right?
Yeah,
and you can't really condense that and
mean you could condense it down,
but you lose a lot of the information
and also you feel like you didn't do it
justice.
Like I can't do those panel shows
because I feel like there's no way I'm
going to be able to do anything justice.
I just as not snow room.
Especially now when people play it up to
they know that they're there for the
entertainment value,
so it's more about being upset at what
someone's saying.
Some real under having some real
understanding.
Right.
It's also about barking out your talking
points in this like ferocious a manner
as you can so that it can appear that
you're winning.
Yeah.
You're a nice guy too though.
You know you're not going to come and
attack somebody.
I definitely don't want to do that.
The the what?
I have people on our.
Even someone that I think I'm going to
disagree with,
I just want.
I wanted to see how they think I want.
Even some people get mad.
They go,
oh dude,
you know,
you more for your opinions based on
whoever's on the show.
That's not what I do,
but what I do do is I let people talk
and I try to see their point of view and
I try to expand their point of view.
So if they say something,
they're also.
So what it is is that this,
and I want them to keep going.
I want,
I want to.
I want to see the whole landscape or
their thought process.
I don't want to want to see a tiny
garden.
I don't want to see a little potted
plant.
I want to see the whole thing.
I want to get a sense of why do I
disagree with them?
What am I fucked up?
Maybe it's me.
Maybe it's maybe it's them should be
too.
I
don't think people should be stuck in
their opinion of even no matter how
right you think you are,
I think you should always be open to
changing your mind.
I think so too,
but I think that's one of the rarest
qualities when it comes to discourse is
the ability that people have to abandon
ideas that they've supported in the past
because
what does that mean then?
If you're on one side and everyone in
your life thinks this way,
what does it mean if you don't think
that way?
Yeah.
Well,
what is.
What are the.
Are Are the ideas you or you,
you and the ideas are just things that
you're.
You're examining.
Yeah,
that's what it should be,
but for most people,
including me,
most of my life,
that was not the case.
If I had an idea and I,
if I supported that idea that I'll
fucking fight you.
This is this arm,
right,
and you're wrong,
and what change?
Then doing this,
doing this podcast changed the way I
talk to people.
Change the way I look at life.
I've talked to so many smart people.
I mean,
I've had a thousand 100,
1200,
1200 podcasts plus all the mma ones.
Um,
there's so many conversations.
So in,
through those conversations I've gotten
at least not a formal education,
but an understanding of things that I
never had before
across a lot of subject.
Yeah.
And through that I think of understand,
I've come to understand not just how I
think about things,
but why,
why,
uh,
I've had road blocks and conversations
before and speed bumps and,
and I've learned,
you know,
I think if you examine your own yourself
and your own thoughts,
you're sure to learn hopefully.
Yeah.
And I think it also can help if you look
at the other side,
it can help you figure out why you
believe what you believe too,
because you can look at them and say,
okay,
I still don't agree with you and this is
why I think if people aren't even
willing to look at the other side and
consider why they might be wrong,
how do you really know?
Yeah.
And then you also run into some people
that they don't really have opinions.
They have these things that they've
adopted,
like slogans.
Yeah,
they,
they've,
they've gotten these things,
they've decided this is what my side
support,
so I'm going to just spout this out and
this makes me seem like I'm a good team
player.
And,
and then the thing about podcast though,
when you sit down for three hours,
you go,
why do you think that?
Like what's going on there?
And then they start talking about why
they think that and then know it all
falls apart and then you realize that
they don't even know why they think
that.
Yeah.
And they probably never even thought
about it before they just been saying
what they've been saying for so long.
Right.
Because it sounds nice.
Yeah.
People love to do that.
They love it.
It's a sport.
I mean there's idea sports,
you know,
an idea.
Sports or arguments,
arguments are so oftentimes idea sports.
Yeah.
Politics too.
To some degree I think.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
But the politics are just so flavored by
money.
The problem with that,
you know,
that version of idea sport is lobbyists
and special interest groups and
different people that are pushing you to
get in the office cause you're going to
change laws and force things through and
that's the trickiest of all idea sports
and also the most shallow.
I mean just think about presidential
debates and speeches and those are the
most shallow discussions in terms of the
actual reality of.
Yeah,
and who that person is.
Who is that person?
Imagine if you were dating someone and
every time you went on a date with them
it was like a presidential speech.
People like,
what the fuck are you?
I don't even know you are.
You don't display any humanity.
Kind of interesting though.
Yeah,
for sure.
Write a book about that.
But that's what we want in leaders,
right?
We want someone who's full of Shit,
who,
who like makes us feel better.
Like they.
Yeah.
That they're speaking like a leader.
You know?
It's weird.
It's weird that we liked these patterns.
So you know,
the,
the presidential speaking pattern is of
a very,
very strange one.
Yeah.
It's soothing though.
Yeah,
I guess in a way,
right?
Yeah.
In a way it's soothing because we want a
big daddy,
big daddy to take care of us,
you know,
tell us everything will be okay.
But as you get older that makes less and
less sense.
Like I'm 50 and so if a new president
was 45,
I'd be like,
that bitch don't know shit.
He know have only been living in 45
years.
Shit,
you know,
but like when you're 30 and the
president's 70 like,
well you make sense he's an established
person,
he's a man of reason.
But is it at the age difference or is it
your own maturity?
Well,
there's a lot of old dummies for sure.
There's a lot of dummies who just
survived because we nerfed up the world
for them.
Yeah,
it's your own maturity.
It's also the amount of time that you
have to examine ideas.
See,
if I worked in a coal mine,
I probably would not have the time to
sit around all day and think shit
through.
There's a a great luxury that you have
when you're,
when you do this for a living,
that you get a chance to communicate
with people over and over and over
again,
and there'll be another podcast.
Tomorrow's another podcast next day.
Every day I'm looking at a new person
and talking to a new brain and trying to
see how it goes on in there.
What's behind the eyes figured out?
Is that why you like it this length?
You know what?
Everybody told me not to do this.
This is where the Arusha fear.
It's famously told me to go to your
podcast.
I go,
why?
No one's going to listen to it for that
long so they don't listen and don't give
a fuck.
Like I'm just going to do this.
He's like,
you should.
Or like,
why?
Well,
this parts that are not good.
I go,
yeah,
those parts you're going to have to
either skip over or just not.
Not downloaded.
I don't give a shit.
The nice thing about long form though
too,
if people know it's not edited,
they trusted a bit more.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah,
there's definitely that.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the like that,
but the,
the,
yeah,
all that.
That's in there.
Character.
That's who you are.
That's who you are and you know,
there's no way you could free ball an
entire three hours and will Sam Harris
can do it.
He's pretty good at it.
Yeah.
Super articulate guy with practice while
you've been doing this a long time.
You're good.
Well thank you.
You're good at it too.
Thank you.
Um,
which did three hours.
Is there anything you would like to,
uh,
to say or Zany thing you didn't?
Don't think we covered.
Mm,
I guess the only thing I'd say we just
launched our first season of wrong
speak.
The second season will be starting in
the fall.
Now.
How are you doing when you're saying
seasons?
So we did three for the first and we're
going to do another cluster of three or
four for the next.
But why are you calling them a season?
Because it's one group and one
particular subjects.
No.
So then,
so next season we're going to do one on
political correctness.
In comedy.
There's going to be one on academic
mobbing and then there's gonna be
another one that's going to be
surprised.
Oh,
so you plan them out way in advance?
Yeah.
Well we do a bit more of a.
it's kind of more of a structure,
like a story.
It's not a long form
thing.
It's more of a more production in there.
I've mostly heard you do other people's
stuff.
Yeah,
probably.
So you're doing a lot of.
How did you.
How did you do a lot?
Well,
I'm not sure how I found out about you,
man.
I'm sure I found out about you online,
but I don't know what it was that,
that led me to one of your interviews.
Probably the Google memo.
I think when I wrote that column
defending Jameson Moore's memo because I
think that's when we first started being
in contact.
Yeah.
But yeah,
I do a lot of stuff.
I'd so I have a week of convert
playboy.com
monthly column for the Globe and Mail,
which is Canada's national newspaper
cohost on wrong speak,
the podcast and I'll be doing hopefully
lots and lots of more stuff going
forward and hopefully we'll do this
again.
I hope so.
This has been so much fun.
I'm totally fangirl now until you have
been watching you as an mma color
commentator forever.
So this has been so cool.
Well,
I thought it was really cool too.
I really enjoyed talking to tell people
how they can find your social media and
all that jazz.
Uh,
I met Dr Deborah,
so on twitter and facebook,
Dr Deborah W,
so on instagram and then you can check
out wrong,
speak at wrong speak and all major
podcasting platforms,
itunes play.
We did a deborah.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Bye everybody.
Mm.